and we hit go live
alrighty
reject the Mundos who's here
who is here who is here prove yourself
who is spending their New Year's Eve or
depending on your time zone your New
Year's Day with us today who for whom at
a time
Sarah Williamson well done well done I'm
making it early early bird gets the worm
oh let's move apart a little bit let's
make room yeah yes yes race summer
welcome here Courtney hammer a little
more lady names in the chat it's nice to
see that's what we've been aiming for
what was the goal for all the 2022 it
was just to expand that now oh dude uh
Tony what's going on Tony Kevin Shepard
Courtney Hamer just trying to share this
link here
um but yeah thank you guys for being
here Lee J science Martha Alex W
remember you guys uh you guys helped
dictate the way this stream goes down
and how we end up talking about what we
end up talking about see there you are
part of the leaders you are the life's
blood of this live stream
um so yeah I wanted to kick it off first
with a couple of thank yous uh first off
thank all of you and if you're watching
this even on a playback
um sincerely thank you I mean 2022 ended
up being a successful year at the reject
Nation tried out some new things uh got
koi the main part of the channel as well
it was really still under the weather
right now okay wish him well that is the
fiercest ear infection of all time he
had it coming he sorted and you guys
should get to know koi in real life
awful humans yes
and uh and uh you know like 2021 was a
great year uh for the for the channel
and uh this year we did more than
Spider-Man no way home so I think it's a
really good success
we did we covered multiple topics we
covered some DC drama and we did a lot
more movie reactions in DC and and
December was a year of um many much
variety I I think December has felt like
a full year
and Heather gear I hear that um in the
chat you're saying this uh that uh the
menu is supposed to be up on oh my God
I'm not remembering my wife is going to
kill me oh my God you're guys I'm
married you're live you can't go back
and edit that in I'm married
she plays this back you know the time
stamp here and um yeah the menu comes
out this week on I think HBO Max so yeah
I think we want to react to that as well
oh there you go there's more more good
things to come I need I forgot to share
the stream my bad oh and for those who
are here please leave a like and uh I
want to thank John for being the most
awesome number dose you could ask for do
my pamper especially for putting
together all these um for every live
stream John sets them up
and I want to thank the prepper team for
being exceptional help they are guests
we've had over the year
um Andrew Gordon Aaron Alexander uh Tara
Erickson
um Michael Tessler Ace Cabrera Roxy
stryer I got to get them all back this
year
who is a trooper at the wedding by the
way she was she was one of the MVPs so
thank you guys all right let's kick it
off now uh now that we can just focus on
the real thing here yeah I need to give
a heads up I put too much bio freeze on
my back and now my back feels like I got
a bunch of needles stabbing me here at
this moment so like a little
uncomfortable the first three minutes
that's what's going on but uh thank you
all for being here uh I hope you guys
are not caught up in this weird weather
that's been happening the ice storms and
all that [ __ ] it's been kind of crazy I
I just missed that coming back from
Colorado like like the night of of the
day I got back it was like oh man all
these flights yeah not even going out
seeing some crazy stories but what do we
got here in the chat oh we got a super
chat from who's this car Lovejoy I see a
c Carter it's got to be Carter it's got
to be the loving Joy find your super
chat I will find
uh Carter thank you for the Super Chat
top gun Maverick is my favorite film of
2022 saw it at my local Drive in the
past summer with my family also congrats
on getting married Greg thank you very
much uh top gun Maverick is definitely
uh I would say my second favorite movie
of the year I have I do have a little
ranking in my mind
um I I think top gun Maverick is my
second favorite of the year I I saw it
the first time we saw it it was a great
you know theater going experience and
the second time I watched I was like is
it just like good for the the thrills or
is it like just a good movie and then
the second time I watched it I walked
out I was like you know what that's just
a good that's just a good story that's
just a good movie with great character I
love that film I thought it was
excellent yeah that's that's the
wonderful thing and looking at your
particular comment and experience I
appreciate that you saw it at the
drive-in and and like a bunch of movies
you know like there's always a
discussion about how to see a movie when
it's a big spectacle like this but top
gun Maverick brings me such Joy because
to me like there's no bad way to see it
and I was thinking about your experience
because we had we saw you know uh what
what I like we had a d-box experience we
had IMAX and I was thinking like man
even watching it in your car would bring
something he had a drive-in would bring
something unique because it's also got
like an Americana quality as a movie in
a weird way so like something about that
seems quintessential and like there's no
bad way to go as long as it's bigger
than your phone or on an airplane or on
an airplane
place to watch it yeah yeah yeah uh Jeff
Emery thank you for the uh the
compliment there Jennifer happy New
Years to you too Happy New Year's doe
Disney fan thank you very much Heather
gear always good to see your name
popping up in this chat Janine would it
do how's it going Janine oh my God oh
maybe we should turn the slow-mo back on
but we'll see it's so good we'll see how
we handle this first
we'll take Life by the horns today karma
for Coy hashtag karma for Coy dude I
feel so bad for koi every time I see one
of his social media posts now I'm like
jeez his voice still has it like he
seems like he's he doesn't stop wrecked
he doesn't stop he doesn't stop he's mad
man stop and then every time I see him
he's like man I gotta slow down like
life is telling me to slow down slow
down I'm like relative to what though
yeah slow down relative to what
I bet the best thing in 2022 Greg was
just from the sick Xbox controller God
damn right oh what's up PVP
yeah yeah
um John uh where would you put nope on
your list nope uh nope would be like a
top five of the Year for me I don't have
like a very sort of confident numerical
ranking so to speak but nope would be a
top Fiverr like I I feel like I like to
know more than a lot of people did I've
heard a lot of people say like you know
various like get out
pretty much unanimous and then us was
very divisive you either really liked it
really don't like it I found a lot of
people who want to know for like but I
really loved what he did with making it
yeah his Jaws in the sky and what he
chose to do with the characters and the
array of themes it's going for like I
thought it had a lot of Quirk it was
really it was some of the most fun but
also simultaneously some of the most
striking horror I saw all year like
there are moments that I still think
about and that still chill me in both
like Gordy I think is one of the most
iconic scenes of the year and one of the
again the most sort of like Stark and
and horrific sequences Tony Stark I want
a Pursuit Of Armor around the horse
I'm a Pursuit Of Armor around this chimp
uh and yeah like Daniel kaluya and Kiki
Palmer and and all the main supporting
casts too like nothing is wasted in that
movie and it's one of those where I feel
like Jordan peeled slam dunked his three
as you you often put it like you know
you clinch that status as a you know
Master a tour of sorts when you get that
third movie that to me was just as
strong as all the others just in a more
kind of uh big spectacle sort of
packaging true true yeah and and for all
the BL I would I would argue it's a
blockbuster horror movie and it's
probably my favorite I didn't see like a
ton of them but it's my favorite one I
saw this year certainly
alrighty alrighty thank you John you're
welcome thank you for the thoughts nope
never stop Bronson plays thanks for
being here Bronson plays
um and Clark man those blizzards are
real Dan v900 thank you for the Super
Chat my friend hope it's gonna have a
good New Year right here
we have a good New Year have a good New
Year
All Quiet on the Western Front is
amazing and that cinematography is
incredible it's on Netflix but really
should have been in theaters just
fantastic well thank you for the Super
Chat I have not seen All Quiet on the
Western Front I just found out they made
this I I do want to start up the the
Yellowstone Universe though oh you're
gonna you're gonna jump with that come
across in your life I mean do you know
about the universe
it is a cinematic it isn't like a
television Cinematic Universe the and I
didn't know that I I I I found myself
down a wormhole like I do sometimes when
I can't sleep okay and it was like the
Yellowstone the Kevin Costner show and
then there's I forget what year it is
but there's some show with Sam Elliott
1923 or whatever maybe my God guys I did
cardio before showing up here and I
showered and I'm still like getting
sexy today stop fogging up here you are
very sexy lately you look like you work
out oh thanks John so do you
thank you for for placating thank you
thank you for the hell I do that that's
just my own body dysmorphia talking like
thank you
that's our new shirt
january.com I worked out because of my
body doesn't work it's like that that Bo
burning it's not making fun of people a
legit habit it's a constant therapy
conversation but yeah but then there's
also the Harrison Ford show yeah so
there is like a cinematic and apparently
they're all like fantastic shows so I do
want to see them
um all right here we go here we go John
this is not moving my mouse isn't moving
John oh it's on the screen okay
um stranger things for the Sandman and
Wednesday took the cake from Netflix you
know I've got John can you switch this
back to his wife yeah like a 30 second
one
um I haven't seen you haven't seen
Sandman yet or I haven't seen Sandman
yet I've seen the pilot episode which I
was very intrigued by haven't seen
Sandman stranger things 4 it's really
tough I was trying to think of my
favorite shows this year and it's either
I I definitely have some favorite uh new
shows that came out this year or like
New Seasons at least uh and obviously we
just started up Wednesday the reaction
the First episodes up on the channel
right now uh but straight I went to the
stranger thing they have this experience
out in uh La called The Stranger Things
experience and I wasn't I thought it was
just something like go to and you like
look at [ __ ] but it's it's a full-on
like immersion theater experience and
they don't let you record it it's like a
half hour long and if you're living in
Los Angeles it's really freaking cool
and it's it's produced by Netflix and I
was surprised by a number I was but as
someone who loves stranger things um I
still feel like better called Saul's my
favorite season of Television this
finale but that might be a nostalgic
Play
Just Because the Breaking Bad Universe
means the world to me
uh it might be stranger things though
I'm not sure yet I haven't properly
figured that out on my own but they're
definitely there they're either way
they're probably like flip-flop
I mean I don't know hearing you talk
about Better Call Saul and knowing okay
here's my Outsider perspective that is
totally valid because I have not seen
Better Call Saul at this point but I
feel like here you talk about it and
knowing the level of
steady consistency that show has I feel
like the smart choice would be Better
Call Saul because stranger things 4 is
like among the best stranger things but
there's also like some wacky stuff about
that it's not a perfect season of TV you
know yes
um
I don't know I really yeah there's but
there's some really amazing it's it's
weird to live in a time where we have
stranger things where you can win years
for a season you know and everybody
still joins him everybody gets around
the water cooler
um Babylon I'm gonna tell you guys I'm
so excited I'm gonna tell you guys about
my experience with Babylon I'm gonna
give slight spoilers like the slightest
spoilers for Babylon oh good
um I found a a a a legal recording
online all right way it was mentioned I
found a cam
because people every time I go on
Twitter I just hear about how it's a
bomb and a horrible film that's all I
hear about and I'll and that it's just
like debauchery crazy and I was like
let's see what else is all shooting on
people so I ran an experiment I just
skipped to every five minutes and
watched for 10 seconds
it took me it took me like 10 minutes to
do this I skipped it every five minutes
and watched for 10 seconds I'm gonna
tell you about the first five minutes
this sounds like a second 10 minutes
okay
um I gotta watch my words here because
it's so easy to get age restricted here
um the first five minutes okay screw it
it's gonna be Adrian welcome to a
segment we like to call watch Greg
dancers no way to explain this without
being blunt with you guys it'll be fun
to watch you try the first five minutes
was this I was like watching like oh my
God this girl uh pees on a fat guy and
fat naked guy five minutes later wow the
girl's dead
like two hours 30. I was texting uh
there's about this in two hours third I
was texting him as I was doing it two
hours 30 minutes
there's a guy a big muscular guy
underground eating a rat I'm like I
don't know how but that's what the hell
this is
you could literally create like sketch
pitches just based off of skipping five
minutes in Babylon 10 minutes and just
picking the first few stimuli and going
with that it's my out of body experience
that is the best sales pitch I've heard
so far I know a few people who love that
movie who think it's great I know I know
so respect the madness I like your
ranking here Carter that's a good
ranking yeah uh Dan V 900 Johnny read it
Vesper is a great sci-fi film that has
themes in common with blood renair 2049
and the game Detroit become human it
also has great cinematography Detroit
I've never heard this game Detroit
become human I'm more of Detroit become
human I'm not aware of Vesper oh goody
let's talk about that Vesper sounds
familiar heavy spoilers been wanting to
do more sci-fi oh dude dude call him up
there's plenty of sci-fi out there I
know he's killing it his Interstellar
video like 750k views right now dude
doing great black hole life thanks for
the recommendation Davy 900 and for the
Super Chat and Chance's house of horror
ooh we want to figure out if there's a
way to get this up on YouTube oh what
are we doing thank you for this a huge
year for horror movies love terrifier
too I was just shouts out to my friend
Roxy was just watching this last night
and uh and it's yeah I have no idea I
mean you know I feel like people would
understand it just being a big blurred
reaction
yeah I was like I was like don't tell me
too much but they were like yeah this is
a this is a horrifically gory movie
We're acting a terrifier too pixelated
uh yeah I'm sure make a fun reaction
I've seen a couple people managed to get
it up on the chat on their channels but
yeah that's uh I do want to see it
though but we'll take this moment to
what was your favorite horror movie they
might yeah I have an easy pick for my
favorite part we have the same is it the
same one because yeah because my number
two horror movie would be nope but my
first and foremost say three two one
barbarian barbarian was we didn't even
go for a joke on that no no no Aryan was
one of the most yeah like locked in Wild
roll it reminded me of that time we went
to the test reading of Drag Me to Hell
in a way where it was like I am having
so much fun I am so on edge I'm jumping
and and you know yeah horrified but also
so engrossed I'm not gonna lie I I
that's probably the biggest surprise of
the Year for me too because and we're
gonna make sure not to like spoil any
movies here too
um there's one of the if you haven't
seen Barbarian I know some people really
don't like it but uh so yeah you have
your own opinion I found I found all
those opinions after we saw it yeah and
the Marvel to me was that I'd heard
everybody be like this is one of the
best movies of the year don't learn
anything is crazy it's gonna blow your
mind and and it's still you know like
that hype didn't affect my viewing
experience almost at all you know well I
I had no I had no vested interest in
seeing this film uh prior to the hype
because that was one of those movies
where Word of Mouth really played a
factor because I heard about like we
were getting invited to screenings and
stuff and I was like I want to see this
piece of [ __ ] yeah there's like a few
different emails just they're really
pushing this movie we're not going to
have the best worst of opinions in this
chat in this video today
um go to the people who see like the
entire swath of Cinema for the year and
they'll give you some good picks for bad
movies I'm often like I don't want to
see it looks like crap oh yeah I gotta
maximize my movie watching I was so
judgment it's my sin that cynical part
of my brain that went off and sometimes
I I I I I don't like that about myself
and it's something I'm working on where
instead of I have to sometimes check my
own cynicism and go no learn to be
interested learn to be fascinated look
into it before judging it and I'd
straight up judge like I don't know
who's in this movie this is some random
Fox film I don't want to see it yeah
arms crossed I didn't even watch the
trailer for a reason I don't care and
then I ended up finding it to be one of
my favorite movies of the year yeah that
was such a nice surprise thank you Ronan
Unchained the Batman to put the Batman
in the thumbnail the Batman it's easy to
forget that well because two like that
so early this year so early in the year
and it was caught up in that same
Whirlwind of like Spider-Man no way home
sentiments because that movie hung
around so I feel like they I don't know
to me those movies created two polls
because because then thinking back on
this list I was like oh yeah you can't
include Spider-Man away home because
that was 20 20. one yeah I think uh hell
jumper Thank You Hell jumper Hells yeah
Avatar way of water brought me to tears
love it I really love that movie too uh
we're I'm finally showing my wife it on
Tuesday Tuesday night
um just to get up so early in the
morning for work
straight back she's gonna be so ready to
protect those kids though
um yeah I I put Avatar as my number five
uh for the Year by the end of this video
you will figure out what my list is my
fully simple list is and and Avatar the
way of water I think this year really
captured like
I think it was Jeremy Johns who actually
said it that really captures that pure
escapism into another world a cinematic
escapism and I can't think of another
movie that's really done that like top
gun Maverick is undoubtedly one of the
movies you go to the theaters for uh but
Avatar the way of water you're like oh
yeah this is the one that if you're
gonna watch this you should go to the
theaters and you sh and this is one that
you gotta do your best to allow yourself
to get lost and immersed into a new a
new world and I love that about the film
and not many movies can do that so yeah
way of water man the way of water and
like it was really magical this year of
2020 one of the few bright kind of
themes in 2022 I thought that was really
nice was that you got Avatar and you got
Maverick which are sort of on two
opposite ends of a spectrum but equally
transportive movie Magic where both of
them are like this is truly cinema this
is truly something you gotta go out and
be with people and be in the big you
know all the bells and whistles
environment to it to get the most out of
but both are so transport of using
completely opposite elements and I I
love that for the overall scope of like
that gives me hope for the entire
spectrum of at least exhilarating
Blockbuster Cinema Amen to that
um okay if we got some in the Stream
Labs we got to go to that in just a
minute veldson says use this to buy
counterfeit ring well thank you for the
Super Chat oh yeah get it delivered here
now my brother's probably gonna be
pissed at me for telling the story but
all the time he did get temporarily
engaged and and when he was extremely
young like like one of those uh you're
young and in love yeah they're just like
still in high school I think and it was
very temporary and then he bought like
uh did one of those like cute 50 cent
rings like like you get at the grocery
store or something like that from Curtis
Jackson
[Laughter]
yeah get richer or die trying thank you
Smokey to Bear next year John getting a
girlfriend you can't tie this guy down
trying for years oh it'll happen no
woman can hold this man down I got
regrets out there don't worry Batman
might be my favorite movie of the year
the Batman there's a lot of love for the
Batman that's great it is absolutely in
my top ten that's so funny um yeah
that's my number uh
I think that's my fourth yeah okay okay
yeah I do love that movie but I was
telling Olivia on the car right back
from the strange things experience like
it's been a while since we've seen the
Batman she's like do we watch the Batman
every week
I don't know
and I just haven't seen it in a while
and it seems like a thing now is the
perfect time because it's raining so
like yeah put it on like this week I
haven't seen it at home yet yeah and I I
have I saw it three times in the
theaters and and this is hours and
that's a three-hour movie that at home
you could still like it's like Lord of
the Rings like you could still like
hunker down and be like oh we're gonna
have a fun watch party and I think still
enjoy the experience
um Heather gear is talking about the
whale I think it just seems like a
Oddball movie to do a reaction to but I
want to do it I want to see it do it man
it just sounds like go for the trifecta
it sounds like
I'm sure I wouldn't make these comments
once seeing the movie because I I really
sympathize for people with like weight
struggles and someone I don't you guys
might have seen like yeah especially
this guy you guys might have you know
seen me years ago when I was much bigger
and stuff and and weight problems and
and body dysmorphia and image
self-consciousness especially about my
body can be very it's been a very like
top like predominant Topic in my life
since I was a little boy and so I really
struggled with it but when I hear about
this movie The Whale for a movie I
haven't seen a trailer for it's called
the whale and all I hear about Brendan
Fraser's really fat and sad
and it's called the whale and I'm like
what the [ __ ] it sounds like the most
depressing [ __ ] in the world but I want
to see it and I'm sure I wouldn't be
like making fun of it for that factor
I'm just happy for the like that misery
porn [ __ ] that you know
I look with it absolutely
sure yeah yeah there's uh you know
you're gonna get into some something at
least interesting is something that's
going to either give you something to
very much appreciate or very much be
passionately you know upset by yeah and
and I do love that we are entering a new
like Brandon Fraser has been back as you
have often pointed out through Doom
Patrol and stuff like that but we're
entering a new Frazier science and I am
I'm here for that it just seems like
more than ever now I don't really have
Heroes and uh people have all been
demystified for me but Brendan Fraser I
see and I'm like
so you seem like a good good human
you're a good guy you and Keanu seem
like a good couple people in the world
and I'm glad you're here I'll support
you happily it's Mayo Montoya thank you
for the contribution my friend Ismail
hey guys my best
my worst Armageddon there was a movie
called Armageddon this year no you just
finally saw the Michael Bay Criterion
classic I also really enjoyed pray pray
best wishes to you guys what are your NY
resolutions praise my number six love
that film as you guys know I was I
really felt like yeah I want to help get
the word out on prey that was one of my
that was the movie that really provoked
that from me yeah that was long Anatomy
that was one of the highlights of the
Year even and even just to watch from
afar because uh because of the
circumstances the time like the the
interviews that you did and then doing
the red carpet like that did seem like a
special one and and like I love the
experience of that movie too and to have
a couple things like Chucky and that to
do like a little bit more personal with
filmmakers and stuff like that like I
feel like we don't often do that and
that's a precarious position to be in
but those were two like ah man like as a
film and and you know arts and media fan
like those were so cool to behold those
moments I I want to do I was talking I
was just talking about the movie the
Michael Bay movie armagedding yesterday
because I've been getting really into
finally in my life uh wife's been
showing me stuff about like Dr Cosmos I
watched another Netflix show like trying
to understand
you know space and time and all these
things that I I don't feel like I'm well
versed enough and
and uh I was like so that she didn't
Armageddon
you can't do this
just drill in and blow it up something
like no do we have the technology to
asterisk but not that Armageddon kind of
yeah yeah and they just tested out a
thing that's supposed to like impact
brace like send asteroids off in all
alternate directions or whatever well
what I was I wanted to do a re-watch uh
I wanted to try doing re-watches on the
channel for 2021 you're asking about New
Year's resolutions and Armageddon funny
enough factors into that because I
haven't seen Armageddon since I was a
kid and I thought like what if I did
like a re-watching Armageddon to see if
I still like it not because of like
scientific facts it's just as as years
have gone on all I've ever heard is like
people talk mad [ __ ] on Armageddon and I
and I haven't seen it since I was like
maybe eight years old and uh yeah and I
want to see like do I still like this
movie you know or did I have space
dementia all along I want to see it I
want to do it again that sounds like a
fun I I hope that series works because
there are a lot of things too that I've
only seen when I was I like the mask or
something like that something like I've
only saw that in the theaters when I was
four I don't remember remember this
work date release thank you for a very
generous Super Chat big fan of you guys
watching listening to you all feels like
hanging out with friends oh cheers 2023
well you know if you ever see us in
person please come say hi good the
agency did their job I had a weird out
of body experience at the gym the other
day where this like whoa really buff
tatted up dude I have my headphones on
I was doing a hammer curl oh cool
Hanukkah cool guy all I do is and then
this guy
uh I see talking to me but I couldn't
hear him
and I took my earbud out and he's like
he's like love the channel
I was like oh thanks man
but I was so intimidated by this guy's
physique and normally I'm like what's
your name I'm gonna bother you until you
don't want to talk to me anymore and
then I just went thanks
I don't know how to keep talking for
some reason I don't want to come across
the wrong opinion and have you break me
in half if you happen to be watching man
if it's out of me again and I promise we
will engage in conversation I will talk
your ear I don't know why I handled it
that way dude someone gave a 200 super
my god oh you can't wait for that one oh
my goodness holy crap thank you so much
I I need to let's get an early mention
at least Colin Ramirez call in all right
we're gonna just we don't really skip
but man that's this is insanely generous
anyone to hear or understand oh my God
Happy New Year's guys extremely crazy
movie list coming out next year it's
gonna be great year much love though
thank you Colin Ramirez thank you so
much holy [ __ ] I know February through
June uh July is gonna be like all
massively stacked movies and shows and
we got a Last of Us
dude you are the new mayor of the reject
Nation for today
um Nora thank thank you Khan that's
that's a very that's a very good I'm the
little uh speechless in this moment
um and we do got to get to these
streamlabs people we don't have them yet
people are often yelling at us oh no
thank you guys okay there is a stream
Labs link though they do take less than
YouTube so only only if you're so if you
want we we appreciate it no pressure
seriously it's whatever you like we just
want to hang out Philip H nope wasn't
good for me
Smokey the Bear says smile
disappointment as well you know it's
just [ __ ] smile I like smiles too you
stood out to me man it did it did and
smile is funny it's funny too because in
the lead up I just heard like oh man
it's killing the box office and we're
like this is the greatest and then I saw
it and then since seeing it now I only
encounter people who are like I don't
know I don't like it I don't like it
it's the way it goes I thought top gun
Maverick might get there and I'm like
thank God it hasn't got it I think yeah
yeah like I'm sure there are people who
don't like it but it's just refreshing
to see a movie that is just getting love
and mainly just gets love and yeah
exactly and even with something like
Avatar where like the first movie has
certainly soured in certain people's
mouths like I it's been refreshing to
hear so many like there are certainly
negative takes but yeah more prevalent
people are like if you're hating not
Avatar to hate on Avatar it's kind of
lame and and you know go get something
else to do you know like I'm happy to
see some good will this year I forget
that Avatar of course made a bunch of
money uh when like you you have to kind
of it's kind of innate with it I know
some people don't do it but more movies
this is like one of the few movies where
people are like no I gotta see something
like premium format yeah even for I
think the average moviegoer who would
rather who can sometimes just go to like
a whatever theater they're like no I
need to see it in like 3D and stuff so
the ticket prices are naturally going to
be higher yeah yeah I'm not saying like
like as an earned this money but but
yeah yeah it's like for the amount of
worry going in and now this week it's
been like the the the weekend it came
out it was like I don't know Avatar
might underperform and now it's like
it's already past a million it's gonna
probably hit two billion pretty soon so
if it doesn't have competition for a
while have not seen men I do want to
check it out yeah
um I think does 2022 rejection was uh
the year of experimenting with what can
we skip out to wait to come out on
streaming to react to react and like men
use one of them you know so there's some
movies that were like that definitely
seems like a reaction type movie just
hearing people talk about it bullet
train like as much as I don't love the
entire movie there is stuff that was
very memorable and and uh and lemon and
tangerine are like two of my favorite
characters of the year you know you
Sarah's saying I think peel and Jordan
Peele and Daniel should work together
again and I'm I'm waiting for the day
when King and Michael Key finally shows
up one of these po movies man yes I
think it's four if he does his fourth
movie it's like okay you have
established King Michael he has his own
career now and you have established you
are separate careers yeah you are
separate people you you're not just
solely lumped in with each other now you
know and I think that would be something
really special and I think Higa Michael
he could pull off a good horror mystery
100 I think he undoubtedly could and I
would love to see Hugo Michael Key and
him reunite under Jordan peele's
Direction yeah Edgar Wright and Simon
Pegg need to come back together yes yeah
you know
um Haunted Mansion releases oh yes I'm
excited I hope it's good I keep always
rooting for them to nail that
he is live action Mario Brothers that's
the
live-action version that would work
um that's a movie I haven't seen since I
was a little child look I'm seeing it
everywhere in the chat and if you can't
I can't deny this everything everywhere
all at once is my favorite movie of the
year it's my in fact it's above number
one for me it's the everything donut
zero yeah it's the undisputable number
for me you were the first person I know
who saw it Oh and then then I started
hearing about it all the time I remember
that day we had an emotional
conversation and then after that fact I
was like I saw this movie man you you
need to check this out yeah you need to
see this and then moments later your
brother texted you about it and you were
like look at this I'm like God damn this
movie's being talked about so much and
and um you know as as much as uh it's
been my life's Mission apparently to
normalize crying for men that is the
thing that is
have you seen the gray you should watch
that on camera I I have no movie broke
me as much as every I couldn't like that
there were times when I was working on
the edit for that film where I'm like oh
man I got like like childish whimpers
happening here and I don't know I'm I'm
even a little bit embarrassed to be
posting this right now yes
I was like doing those noises but it was
also so exciting like that to me was a a
pure and one of the main I won't say
which one
um but one of the the main producers
I'll I'll leave it at that uh actually
hit me up on Instagram after seeing that
reaction it was like thank you for doing
that because it really she said
something along the line of you're the
best person in the world no he says this
is the 100 reaction we have hoped for
said that uh it's something another
reminder of you know like was why we do
movies like this you know so thank you
it is and that was and and I I then that
was the only movie that we reacted to or
at least I did where I immediately I was
like I got these in the theaters and a
few days later I did yeah my wife to see
it and yeah like that was again just
[ __ ] snotty no totally and it's one
of those movies it's one of those Great
Moments movies that has multiple moments
where you have that emotional like wait
what is happening to me right now and
yeah like seeing it again in the theater
same same it's like in moments I wasn't
expecting like early on it was just like
okay I guess I'm just gonna have like a
constant flow of Tears going and it's
just gonna pick up or or fall down for a
little bit like it might be replaced by
fun but I'll be crying again pretty soon
cyan shock reporting Happy New Year to
you as well okay
um I haven't seen these are morph
pointed out movies like Amsterdam which
I'm still going to watch and I find it
funny how Margot Robbie is just a part
of Ensemble movies I know and she's
getting like she's getting the the
[ __ ] [ __ ] like right now yeah
she can't like lead a movie as just a
lead either Amsterdam had like Christian
Bale and John David Washington that's a
lot of other things going for it yeah
and uh yeah you know in The Suicide
Squad had a lot of different factors
going against it and so yeah you know
like and Babylon she's obviously the
lead in it but people were like rap hits
not a lead and I did that every skipping
five minutes and he was in it throughout
I don't know what I was doing the one
I've heard it said that in Babylon it's
really the other guy the the guy who is
the real lead Cipher character the guy
who like works his way up from elephant
poop scooper the Northman sure that's
another one we want to do a reaction to
and I guess row is up in the air about
violence like yeah like we could do it
and we could blur the [ __ ] out of it and
because I heard it's like a lot of
nudity and violence sure but I'm like
will that make for an unenjoyable
reaction we just have to take our shirts
off for the reaction yeah real jacked
and do the 300 workout and then watch it
with our shirts off I mean my favorite
shows of of the year were was
undoubtedly Better Call Saul
and uh I've mentioned this early in the
Stream Better Call Saul stranger things
for
um Andor it was great yeah I mean I I I
like I liked Westworld more season four
so it really bummed me out when that got
canceled I really love Westworld season
four
um I just love the world and tone of
that and House of the Dragon it was
great to just have some awesome event
asked television again and also a bit of
a Redemption art for Game of Thrones I
know that was very great as much as I
was like uh apathetic going in I was
very gratified to see them get some
Redemption from that uh what was your
favorite show of the year
um you know thinking back man like is
there one you watched that wasn't here
I I went back and watched Atlanta season
three which I really I saw most of that
I really enjoyed I haven't finished it
but lately I've been watching the bear
everybody like talking yeah has been
talking about it and recommending it and
and it is like very gripping and and
kind of magical so that's that's been
something I've really enjoyed kind of
getting into at least for the year I'm
trying to think if there was like a
series that I really started and
finished maybe it'll come to me but yeah
most of the most of the involved TV I
have watched has been either here or or
directly related to something we're
doing here uh yeah Jurassic world
Dominion veltzon um thank you for the
Super Chat earlier yes Jurassic world
Dominion
I that that was uh that's definitely one
of the worst movies of the year it's not
to me the worst
like there's a lot of bad films
apparently that came out that I just
have not seen it's not my number one
worst movie
uh it's probably like three years
no it's probably like two I really was
surprised by because I was so that move
that trailer
had me back just when I think um
and that trailer did it I was like they
learned their lessons from the last day
oh I fixed it it's gonna be good gonna
give us the movie we won look they got
the returning cast I'm a big fan of
duress I really Champion for Jurassic
world uh the first one I know that one
also gets a lot of crap I really like
that one and I championed for Jurassic
world Fallen Kingdom weirdly enough
and that film was a slog it was a loud
it was a loud slog it was really hard
for me to get through and I fell asleep
it definitely dozed off a few times
which is kind of hard to say for a film
of that bombastic caliber it's like
started zoning out and just literally
like oh my God yeah stay awake yeah
something about the spirit something
about the attitude of those movies is
just like off-putting when combined with
all the other things they have colliding
and it's funny because I liked like I
liked the pilot character and I didn't
mind the locusts and I thought Tim Cook
was funny but yeah that was such like a
just to meet you on the Locust part I
literally wasn't one of those people
who's like freaking walked out to film a
little bit much look stuff done I'm like
I don't know it makes sense there were
big bugs back then big bugs are just as
creepy that's fine like it wasn't like I
liked the Locust part but I wasn't like
pissed it was it was the least
bothersome thing to me and it was the
thing I saw the most people focusing in
on so I was like I don't really care
about that if the rest of the movie was
good or like these Legacy characters
felt like they were being in any way
serviced by the plot and if it felt like
Chris Pratt actually was like in the
movie with everybody else but you know
what what came to me just now uh
probably the best show I saw this year
outside of of what we've done for the
channel uh was reservation dogs I really
I saw the first season reservation dogs
in the FX really liked that show yeah
the FX show
um and I would highly recommend that
like it's got a similar quality to like
it's it's a bit of a drum it's a bit of
a comedy it's a bit quirky it's not like
full-on absurd but there is a certain
element of absurdity so it is like a
good neighbor to an Atlanta type show
but uh it's it's it's great it's really
well done
I can't wait to talk about Halloween
ends oh good Corey Cunningham let's do
it my dudes we'll get there I didn't
revisit any of the moves that might come
up so I just remember the lasting
feeling and not the specifics because
yeah because we like talked for a long
time about Halloween ends and I've had a
very long conversation conversation and
now I'm like I forgot everything about
that about my specific opinion go back
and watch it with fresh eyes okay you're
gonna like it darn I do not see eye to
eye uh Ethan wenzloff uh would you
consider reacting to Severance thank you
for the Super Chat by the way uh
Severance is one that
you know what Severance is one of those
that I might
we might like maybe watch on our own
time and then when it comes back with a
new season be like all right or react
yeah it's held on the conversation yeah
but it's one that there are certain
shows I I like to just sort of
experience without a camera pointed at
me oh my god look we got a super chat
here from Mar uh streamline from marsay
production
and there's it's a moment of silence
there's there's literally nothing there
thank you
if you have a question please pop it up
in the chat so we can acknowledge it
thank you Marseille Productions
flevtavius Doran over here let's uh
let's switch it back Johnny oh do we
want to read flev
uh oh fleb did someone yeah here I'll
I'll uh I'll get this so that we are a
little more visible on screen thank you
flev yeah thanks buddy all right best
film top gun Maverick best show how wow
we are so eye to eye here House of the
Dragon Better Call Saul I am so sorry
there we go uh underrated show the
terminal list haven't seen the terminal
list and yep you named the worst film
I've seen all year Pinocchio
so much so
that I haven't even taken the time to
watch garamondo Toro's Pinocchio I am
very excited for that because I'm like I
just want to not think about Pinocchio
right now that movement was inexplicable
and and we did a reaction to that film
before any social media embargo lifted
any reviews lifted
and so we we didn't have any like
preconceived thoughts about it sucky you
know no I was actually looking forward
to the combination elements yeah so was
I and and then uh that became easily the
most tedious
reaction experience to do what happened
to zemeckis man that was that was he
needs a television show he needs a TV
show with a tight budget yeah yeah it's
a Tim Burton Wednesday situation here
only a little bit of CGI wise where you
use it Pinocchio was the worst movie of
of the worst movie I saw this year am I
not I'm sure certain films I haven't
seen but that was the worst that was
yeah easily beats Uncharted in Jurassic
world dimension for me yeah because it
uh because even those have little things
that work or that ironically work in
Pinocchio like you can hate watch and
ironically watch it but even with that
Sheen you're like this is not it just
gets worse yeah and it manages to like
fumble the charms of the original movie
and take out like all the impactful
elements so that it's just kind of like
a weird
kids can't drink root beer I guess like
I don't know don't don't drink too much
root beer worst shows haven't seen the
Winchesters uh obviously you're not
gonna start that though Supernatural
worst finale Ozark oh no way I wanted to
start Ozark is that a common opinion is
that a common opinion I don't know I
haven't heard too much outcry switch
back to the chat yeah absolutely well
thank you flev damn that's crazy to hear
I'm sad I'm sad for that and the
Winchester's I saw the Winchester's at
100 on Rotten Tomatoes but then I
realized that like especially with that
[ __ ] especially with network shows
particularly it's always like yeah we we
got the pilot maybe one other episode
had this hundred percent is just based
off all that yeah make sure we didn't
miss anything John can you refresh that
please I don't miss a boot I do I miss
beats sometimes
uh yeah cuckoo gotta watch the Batman on
4K oh yeah no I bought the Batman on 4K
uh that's that's how we're gonna uh Nick
said it here I heard some outcry that uh
that the the score did not get nominated
which is bullsh if it is true because
that's uh one of the scores I've thought
of the most in fact I would love to get
the vinyl it was like a beautiful Mondo
vinyl
okay so yeah we're a tad no
uh we're a little behind oh yeah we're a
little bit behind here okay yeah we
gotta pull this can you pull this menu
up on here because I want to make sure
we don't uh yeah yeah we're definitely
this chat went a little too uh uh we we
we we took too long so it's an often
common complaint of people who
contribute to it we took too long to get
to them we just put too much care and
love into tending to the chat now that's
all that is not rewinding far enough for
us to see so we're gonna we'll bring the
chat back on screen in a little bit we
just wanna
we think it's messed up
we gotta get to everybody we're gonna
bring the we'll bring the public chat
back up on screen a little tiny bit okay
so we
return all right
John you're way too far I know I know I
know you're way too far come on John get
your [ __ ] together reacting to Severance
okay here we go Marcus Santos
Marcos thank you Marcus
um oh I've seen Spectacular Spider-Man
and I've used my influencer skills to
get other people to watch oh uh I love
it I actually like it more even though
it ends on a on a cliff and like show
does not conclude uh I love it uh yeah I
mean we should we should consider that
topic I would be I don't think koi has
seen it either I would be thrilled yeah
me and me plus koi plus animation seems
to be a good combo I mean he can he can
collab with whoever he wants but I will
I will always Avail myself they they end
up doing what's it's not doesn't like
kick off this way but they end up doing
what Remy's Spider-Man 3 ought to have
been
hearing you and Aaron talk about it over
time like has got me very excited to see
it got me the DVDs for it yeah before it
was on streaming um Yeti X thank you
Yeti uh Johnny hope you guys had a great
year can't wait to see what else you
guys do much love proud of you both
thank you Yeti X very good part of why
we had a great game absolutely Gentile
stranger things 4 was amazing but
nothing puts me in the fields like and
or so many emotions like anxiety to
grieve to despair to Hope Great
Performances absolutely I think you know
as much as I like I really loved Andor I
feel like the reason why it's not like
top three for me is because I still had
a bit of that
Star Wars
just the baggage yeah it comes with the
entirety of the year's worth of Star
Wars much as I watch all the Star Wars
animated included I I'm still like ah
yeah those Little Star Wars out but I
thought that was I still thought it was
in its own way I know I get crap for
saying this but in a lot of ways it does
stuff better than the Mandalorian in my
opinion and and uh like I I prefer
watching the
mandalorians it's more exciting yeah
that's more badass yeah and it's got
like it's got more of the adventure
adventure and the coolest one exactly
yeah it's got the star it's got this
it's more Star Wars
and or really is like 80s Ridley Scott
making Star Wars you know like I want to
do my own thing yeah yeah isn't
Rebellion harsh
um and and I I hated arguing people
about Andor because sure yeah yeah it
was one of those shows I was just like
Jesus guys that's let people enjoy it
would you yeah that's something that
takes a nice thing and and adds a layer
of that like yeah come on like I want to
make sure we don't lose our spot here in
the regulars public chat where are we
going uh everything is destroyed now
because of the changing of the oh really
of the scope yeah so uh or well maybe
not I don't know uh but yeah changing
the the size of the text okay so once we
get to Ash Chase we can bring back the
public job okay cool uh Aris uh thank
you Aries hey there have you watched the
whale yet I feel like it was one of the
most if not the most divisive film 22-2
well early in this chat we were talking
about
um possibly doing a reaction here on the
channel
and making
um obese jokes the whole time yes so
that way we lose all our subscribers
that's right that's right man it's about
the time we got Nicole arbored we should
do we should look like total [ __ ]
just like a slight Smurf the whole time
just keep trying to hide her
make a bunch of ironic thin jokes no
that movie I feel like that movie's
going to to break me sure
um it's gonna be so I loved Aaron
aaronovsky and it seems so raw yes and
uh but I'm surprised by the low because
his critics usually eat up his like sad
ass [ __ ]
uh yeah I mean it's been it's been
fascinating too to to hear um just you
know uh fat people talk about it I don't
know what the most sensitive way to put
it is but like uh a fair amount of
people I've seen in my vague you know
dealings with the outside world have
been like you know you know like your
fat friends see your responses to this
movie and you know like hearing some of
those perspectives is an interesting one
as to like the lived-in experience
versus people who haven't lived closer
to that experience I think Brandon
Frazier was a coward for not gaining 400
pounds not going all the way
jeez Christian Bale would have done it
Christian Bale would have done he would
have risk his life for the art
um s oh yeah s Sun comp here's an
interesting one favorite a24 movie of
the year isn't uh is it everywhere
I I wanted to see Marcel the Shell with
Shoes On so bad and I didn't make it oh
yeah movie looks really good I know I'm
so excited this [ __ ] is doing it for me
I I really want to see it I'm excited
let's I'm gonna I'm gonna briefly Google
we can move on briefly Google a list of
their movies this year in case we forgot
one but I feel like everything else we
either haven't seen or it's not
everything everywhere
Mark leads some beautiful man from UK
thank you hope your New Year's going
well
um is it New Year in do you okay yeah no
no no eight hours ahead yeah so it's
it's getting close happy New Years guys
have you seen the menu no we are
planning on I think it comes out on HBO
Max this week and we are planning on
doing a reaction to it and it's your
birthday happy birthday dude I didn't
know that happy birthday dude happy
birthday to us on your birthday that's
how it works undo on my birthday I just
throw out I just I'm like here's my
debit card please take it rack yourself
up something nice Von Rouse
um I really enjoyed thank you Von raster
Super Chat I really enjoyed Elvis and
I'm not a big fan of Elvis Presley but
that movie made me a fan and also made
me cry I'm also a huge Game of Thrones
fan so I'm going to be biased for the
house of the Dragons my favorite show of
2022. good calls I don't believe you're
feeling that way I think it's Paul heavy
spoilers favorite show of the years but
um yeah God oh my goodness I think
Austin Butler is phenomenal in that film
he's absolutely phenomenal and you
forgive him for becoming Elvis in real
life when you see it I I feel like if he
won I would not be upset I would not be
upset I think it's it seems like the
biggest topic of conversations between
him and Brennan Fraser is the skinniest
guy or the fattest guy
that is yeah that's the the smackdown
performance
skinny is the reward for scariest
performance I would not be I would love
for Brendan Fraser to win though man I
would love it I feel like oh God that
would make me so happy for the man
Brendan Frazier dude absolutely that
would be amazing and yeah that film was
uh I'd like to watch it again and it did
have that thing where I'm like what was
true I didn't know half that [ __ ] about
Elvis sure and I grew up listening to
Elvis a bunch and I hope but I don't
know I mean after I feel like a Bohemian
Rhapsody re-upped on everybody's sense
of like we should check out the history
for Real about these movies in case they
tweaked everything so I'd be curious to
know what is accurate they definitely um
downplayed the age difference sure
between
um
the love of his life oh oh God and some
of the grooming that Elvis did that
reminded me of uh of Lockhart my 15 year
old wife I think that's what they were
making funny yeah absolutely absolutely
like we can't make Elvis that unlikable
Kim really quick age 24 I did not
realize what a prolific year they had
just to name like a few of their notable
titles aside from everything everywhere
in Marcel like after Yang Pearl X bodies
bodies bodies men like the whale I
didn't realize that their whole year
Causeway I really want to see like they
they are like the biggest tiny Studio
it's fascinating Ronin Unchained hey
Greg and John C 1883
don't need to watch Yellowstone to love
it all good there you go all right I'll
skip Yellowstone Guillermo del Toro are
these about like the national parks is
this like about the frontier is this a
like a national park Cinematic Universe
or are they like fighting over oil or
some [ __ ] like that no it's about the
national parks and its environmental
message really for real Taylor messing
with me
dude who's gonna watch that I would I
was about to be like Cinematic Universe
based off that I love national parks
pretty and dark and there's violence
characters Red Dead Redemption people
are killing each other to respect land
Guillermo del Toros Pinocchio is my
favorite film of the year I'm so excited
I guess I'll watch it yeah I'm sure I'll
love it by the time I get around to it
reaction I don't know uh men is the most
disturbing and in the top ten I'm very
curious to see that I've heard of a lot
of different opinions about it
fascinated to know Tulsa King chainsaw
man and or range of TV range of TV
chainsaw man I keep hearing about Tulsa
King James
the anime and then Tulsa King is
I saw the trailer for it looked fun it's
also Taylor Sheridan chainsaw man no no
no uh yeah oh cool all right no he's
like dominating I think he's got some
like crazy contract with Amazon right he
must
um he's killing it thank you and
Unchained for the super thank you guys
for the support
um Janine the machine
John read it was hyped was hyped for all
the horror we got this year Barbarian
and bodies bodies bodies really
surprised me love them
well thank you for the super tragedy uh
bodies bodies bodies is one of the
things we have on the list to cover yeah
in fact the last time I saw Janina she
was watching the kill count and I had to
skillfully block out all of that
information which I did
but uh yeah I'm very excited for buddies
buddies buddies that that Pete Davidson
boy
Pete Davidson a big 2022 I know
I like to stand up here he did too dude
my only time in New York City on the one
day the one half a day I went to see my
friend Bryn do stand-up comedy and and
Janine Garofalo was the headliner of
that particular show but Pete Davidson
dropped in to try Away really yeah it
was actually funny they talk about yay
he did not it was way before that this
is like this is like five years ago
um yeah you should have preemptively
started the beef Jacob love
thank you Jacob I saw a glass onion and
Puss in Boots too both good surprisingly
good things about Puss in Boots too
Shrek is the king franchise of having
like that randomly good late stage
sequel if you like Puss in Boots was a
surprise for people sure as like a
genuinely really good movie I don't
remember it I was baked when I watched
it never seen it and then Puss in Boots
too
um that was uh catnip that's getting a
lot of love right now it is I think it's
like two of Puss in Boots I think when
it's out I do a re-watch for Puss and
Boots because I I don't know I don't
remember it I was big I didn't see it
Greg used to constantly be way too big
for too many things back then and
excited this is the new react series
Greg was baked Greg was baked the Greg
was baked cereal Greg watches sober
thank you Jacob sober rewatch and then
I'll do a first time drunken reaction
um film punch thank you film
hey guys
can't tell you my sorry I heard you
drawing breasts to read this and I was
like
I can't tell you my number one favorite
so I don't spoil my own video that being
said one of my favorites of 2022 is pray
Happy New Year I'm glad so many people
are taking time to shout that movie out
because I feel like it would be an easy
one to maybe forget about by the end of
the year given what position it is in
but I love the love for prey I need to
rework my list a little bit I might bump
avatar for prey I would put prey above
this one was such a cinematic experience
but I imagine like if I'm watching these
both at home well that's the great the
great thing is pray you know I saw for
the first time at home and then we went
to the screening and both were great
experiences yeah whereas Avatar I would
only want to really watch the theater in
the
thing or like in a few years on TV to be
like wow these effects still look good
my TV still looks good when I win the
lottery and build a real IMAX screen
I would gladly do that buy whatever
building is adjacent and yeah
um poven mirror povin Meyer
best TV
Better Call Saul
yes
not enough I see a lot of people out
there who are like love Breaking Bad
Breaking Bad break I've had people like
Breaking Bad favorite show of all time
have a seat Better Call Saul yet you're
not a real fan you're the only ones who
disappoint me
that's right do better it's your
favorite I think you gotta complete it
with Better Call Saul sure
um it pays off your patience it will be
rewarded and or I'm glad Anders left an
impact bless you I'm hoping that when
season two comes around it has a lot
more viewership because it had a it had
some residual that I think left people
not wanting to go check it out and I
hope the word of mouth does spread like
I've I Remember by the time episode
three was out I was buying something
from a store and the lady behind the
counter had the Star Wars shirt on it
was like one of those geek stores and
she's like Star Wars my thing I love
Star Wars and she's like yeah but I have
no interest in watching and or I have no
interest in watching it well I really
should though you really should she was
like yeah obi-one kind of let me down
and you know
her man and she's like and there's
nothing about Andrew that looks really
interesting to me I'm sorry I hope she
still watching him the whole 12 episodes
is interesting well I'm glad that they
made the cut though because like
especially now that streaming seems to
maybe be approaching some sort of burst
where people like we cannot put all the
money into everything I'm glad they're
still moving forward with season two
um and then everything everywhere all at
once that is my he's a my favorite movie
of the year Avatar wear water top gun
Maverick yeah yeah it's got to be
everything here my top twos everything
everywhere all at once top gun Maverick
yeah let me see some Tom Cruise love me
some Tommy Cruz man Tommy C oh oh the
house of the dragon as well yeah can we
try to bring back the chat uh on screen
sure is it gonna mess it up are we going
to lose our spot here uh
but we should have enabled slow mode if
I don't change anything we can make it
work let's see what it looks like on
screen all right
back there we go oh good just me yes
that's perfect this is the plan
it's
perfect uh yeah let's change the
dimensions a little bit all right
there we go just for just temporarily
it's temporarily all right there you go
we can still we can still separate them
movie fan I want you to know John and
Greg are planning on watching this movie
yeah I'm reacting to Violent night dude
Pete dude you know what Violet Knight
has I've seen a a funny amount of like
it's really doing a lot for santa-shaped
men people are like man David Harbor is
Santa like give me some break me off a
piece you know thick daddy let's do this
I am so happy that movie's getting a
positive response because that red like
flopped to me you know that red light
failure because I feel like people don't
dig those kind of films yeah and yeah
right now I feel like people are like oh
edgy Santa Claus cool bro the trailers
didn't weren't really cutting it for me
either saw a couple of them in the
theaters I was like
reminded me of like a fat man titled
trailer response where you're like cool
like neat idea cool fine whatever I
probably won't actually see it well the
trailers registered to me like it would
it would hold back from its premise sure
that it wouldn't really commit yeah
fully to what it is but I hear it does
yeah and I've heard everyone the the
number one take I've heard is like but
it really does like have an enduring
Christmas message David Harbor isn't
just a badass like makes sense why is
the character the way he is like okay so
yeah I've heard a lot of yes like
qualitative backup that's good to hear
we are planning on reacting to it I'm
always rooting for David Harper Ash
choice
dude thank you Ash for the Super Chat
I'm super excited about Ant-Man 3 and
guardians of galaxy vol 3 what are your
guys top Marvel movies this year from
Australia
eternals black panther wakanda forever
easily
and you know what I still defend
Multiverse of Madness I I want I will
sometimes go on YouTube just to watch
certain scenes from Multiverse and
Madness sure I I like I unders I I am
fully aware of the flaws the movie has
and I agree with a lot of them
um and the thing though is I I can't
deny I just find it a really
entertaining film and I think it's it's
got some of
arguably my favorite moments because I
just love Wanda in that and I know this
is a big part that can often create a
bit of a divide is the Scarlet Witch a
lot of people especially people like koi
I feel like there's a missing Gap there
but I'm like I don't know it didn't
bother me
and I love One Division that sure so I
really I really love just the she's just
one of my favorite villains and she's so
excellent I love how she just morphs
into this like Terminator yeah like when
she's chasing them in the
after she defeats the Illuminati I love
the context of how [ __ ] up that is to
do to an audience sure like you reeled
him in with this excitement and with an
okay interpretation of these people like
none of them are that Exquisite yeah in
their depictions on screen like they're
really could have done a better job to
make them more distinct or make them
shine more the Illuminati
um but the I'm actually just like wipes
them all out after getting so hard it's
something I just take so much glean well
that's the thing yeah it's it's weird I
am in the minority of people who really
liked Thor love and thunder and who
it's we like in some ways I feel like
that movie is a more smooth overall
experience than Multiverse Madness but
Multiverse of Madness yeah it's like I
would put wakanda forever easily at the
top it was the most emotional it managed
to check all the boxes without any
asterisks uh and and to do something
sort of impossible seeming and something
very communal and beautiful and then
Multiverse Madness was like the opposite
where it's like this doesn't even really
a hundred percent like Multiverse of
Madness feels like a Multiverse a
variant of of a movie it doesn't feel
like the original Nexus version of the
movie but it feels like one of many
versions of what this movie could be to
me yeah uh but yeah what shines is there
are some Immaculate moments and as a fan
of Sam raimi's Direction just getting to
see him in a blockbuster scenario that
also is fully him and isn't constrained
like an Oz the Great and Powerful it was
like so gratifying just as a film fan
that yeah it's like even though
even though I personally like I would
still put Thor at like number three
behind that and then those are the three
movies right we're missing a Marvel
movie oh wait no but there's like the
werewolf dude specials count because I
would say it would be this I would count
this one it would be wakanda forever
then where we'll find out yeah I think
we have doctor strange I think we have
maybe Guardians uh I would put Guardians
I put it after Doctor Strange yeah and
then love and thunder is definitely the
the bottom of of the ranking there for
me but um yeah I think we have the same
ranking on that one
yeah there we go are we live we are live
I know we're really behind on the chat
I'm sorry triple X dad Avatar Two better
win for VFX and you know guys uh I have
a I I do have a I love master class that
and if you guys don't use masterclass if
you're an aspiring filmmaker please get
it
um you don't need to use our promo code
or some [ __ ] like that like I I was that
was one of those companies that I was
I'm bringing this up for a reason on the
subject of Avatar it was one of those
um brands that we did one deal with that
I really wanted to do because I was
already using them for a while and the
like I have it on my phone and and you
get access you pay for like an annual
membership and you get access to all the
classes and and the best way to learn is
from experts and they're so well done
they're better than any kind of like you
know we have the director breaking down
a scene way better than any of that [ __ ]
and and James Cameron has a course and
it is so so
nominal like as someone who's been
wanting to dip his tone to directing
I've any the breakdown of scenes and the
and the breakdown of getting these low
budget films made like Terminator when
he was an unknown name and how they got
that done and what makes these scenes so
iconic and his the way he goes step by
step frame by frame
makes you go wow that's that's how it's
done that's how you make the movie
that's why James Cameron is where he is
because of that thought process you get
such insight and Aaron sorkin's writing
class amazing so yeah I mean I would I
would promote masterclass for free any
day of the week because I think it's
life-changing and I've met other
producers other directors who who swear
by this by master class I think is so if
if there's an investment to making
yourself if you're an aspiring
um like writer filmmaker or even actor
they have like Natalie Portman teaching
class other actors teaching classes
do it I think I if I'm not mistaken I
think they are still running a buy one
get one free subscription so oh really I
think it's amazing yeah I'm gonna sign
up another shout out to Colin Ramirez
Colin Ramirez thank you again for that
massive you are
you're lovely the boys still stay so
strong I love the boys the boys I love
the boys boys are such a treat so good I
wish I could see the book it's the one
show where I'm like I wish this was a
few more episodes honestly like I
appreciate that it's not because I think
that helps them be able to do all the
things that they want to do uh
especially yeah but oh my goodness this
season and Jensen Ackle and now Jeffrey
Dean Morgan is going to be on the next
season and before you know Jared let's
cap it all off yeah they've said like
it's just it's just he's gotta you know
take a break from dude Walker we'll have
money yeah yeah boys is great
um Wednesday Wednesday just started
Wednesday and Anthony Starr is just one
of the most consistent villains yeah
he's so it's it's someone who didn't
read the comic and was I I can put
myself back in the shoes of what it was
like watching the first season and being
unsure like where do we fall here with
homelander sure oh God yeah how bad is
this remember those days it seems bad
but how bad maybe he's misunderstood is
he gonna be like the final episode where
they do some reveal like oh he's
actually a villain you know like an
Icarus in the turtles you know like is
that what they're gonna do how simple is
that and then when they go to that plane
scene
and he's like like he he does he puts
down the the facade and threads get away
from me yeah
yeah and the believability of that line
delivery
and he's just been such a great
deterioration of a human being oh slowly
over these seasons and it just keeps he
remains so constant that is like a Gordy
level that sequence has always stuck
with me as one of the most chilling yeah
like that's one of the most chilling
sequences I've seen in recent life I
remember you were watching like you're
not showing like a computer or something
and I said but when you get to that
airplane episode you should watch it on
the TV yeah so you should why you gotta
watch it on a TV yeah I did that yeah
because oh my God that that that was
like I was I was like gripped and and
like my heart rate was up but I was also
like I almost want to cry this is so
ugly and horrible and disgusting
um Francisco
oh my God that's a friend's reference
hey I have a thank you for the super
Chava doubt do men still beat their PP
after wedding yeah
more more than before yeah I didn't even
do it before and now that I'm married
all the time now I'm like no I have to
have you heard the the I can't say the
name of this song uh no I can't it's
called diaper money it's a lonely island
song but that kind of reminded me of
there's a very funny yorm a verse about
you know he's you know he can't
basically the joke is he can't have sex
at all unless his wife says he can this
is married life uh ooh hey Elvis G this
should be take it for a job they should
make a YouTube film Awards with all the
top YouTube film channels as the voting
panel oh that would be so qual well next
week I wanted to do a live stream on uh
favorite channels of 2022. oh Coolio I
know what my favorite channel is but
but I would like to talk about all the
other ones yeah
um yeah I would like to do that uh hey
glad you listen started cleaning
thoughts on morbius
didn't mind it it was so right it was
one of the movies of 2022 not good it's
not good it's not terrible but I like
that movie seemed to piss people off so
much and I'm like yeah sure I get it why
not but what you this is about what I
expected and uh everyone talks so much
crap on it that I didn't find it as
atrocious as people led me to believe
because no one told me a single thing
that was good about it yeah so the
things that were good about it stood out
to me yeah because no one prepared me
for actually Matt Smith it's pretty fun
yeah yes life of Nate he isn't yeah
no one and because the trailers hit him
so much yeah I thought he'd be in it for
like 10 minutes yeah I'm like oh he's
actually a character throughout
supporting villain yeah I I enjoyed uh I
I had a an enjoy I I have no desire to
re-watch it um but I I love the meme and
I'm glad that more of you was part of
this year's conversation and and yeah I
feel like everybody it's one of those
Hive mindier movies where people don't
care and also don't have a reason so
everyone's just like oh yeah it's
terrible and then you actually look at
it and you're like you know you can
actually consider this in a few
different ways but you know it's a good
time it's fine it's fun it's a meme
Dolan duck then Christopher Nolan duck
have you seen triangle of sadness no I
haven't even heard this oh I want to
every so many people in the last two
weeks have referenced that movie and
also referenced it as like a touchstone
for other movies of the year
so no well I think Nicholas Holt or
somebody enjoy that show Joe I don't
know it's a movie it's a film you enjoy
that movie I will I will have great fun
with my triangle of set I I did I don't
think this is going to get we gotta make
sure we bring up at least everything
that's brought up in the thumbnail at
some point what's in the thumbnail
we're talking about Jurassic world
Uncharted was uh we will get to that
Uncharted was not good but it was a fun
not good
um kind of there's a job
um it's inexplicable sure uh Sarah
Williamson yeah dude if you ever meet us
in real life give us a hug yeah the
biggest hug the biggest longest most
awkward hug cinnamon goodness happy New
Year John and Greg oh it's us
Avatar 2 Batman
bpwv uh w e should be what is it black
panther forever
um Glass Onion nope sorry
Glass Onion yes nope top gun Maverick
Grove by night and light year for the
rest of my top 10. you know what shouts
out to light year shouts out to the
amount of crap that movie gets I thought
it was mesmerizing I was really yeah man
I was eclectic watching that film I I
really enjoyed the [ __ ] out of that
movie and I hear so much people even my
favorite Channel talks crap on that film
and I'm like oh that bums me out wait a
minute okay I got a favorite podcast
sure because yeah no this is the the
number one movie of the year where every
time I hear it brought up people do
discuss it seemingly in those terms like
this is just a bad movie and I'm like
wait what movie did I see like I get
that I get the argument that this maybe
isn't the kind of movie a kid would love
for your Buzz Lightyear movie that you
probably imagined yeah but at the same
time I was here for this
interesting sci-fi Adventure I mean I
think they're mistake was not clarifying
the one sentence that clarifies
everything I think Pixar would have been
fine if they didn't put it in the Buzz
Lightyear realm if there were things
that were like
it's not if there were qualities
because because it would have eliminated
all kind of preconceived expectations or
Notions or whatever and I think it would
have probably had a better response if
they just made it a completely original
Ip because it's not really Buzz
Lightyear it doesn't yeah you could
change some [ __ ] around and then they do
yeah and then people could go okay it's
it's kind of like if it Buzz Lightyear
was the real guy yeah and then you could
liken it to you could go it's kind of
it's the way like when you watch the
elemental trailer or elements whatever
that Pixar movie is and you're like oh
kind of little soul
yeah yeah and I think it would have
gotten a better response
um on that tune I really do want to make
time and try and catch strange world
yeah like like the stream people I've
heard that uh oh yeah leave a like I
don't they're pushing their gay agenda
so it was light year yeah they put the
skating up the screen yes the gays are
attacking uh Bros do you like Bros there
are certain YouTube channels out there
that I love I loved Bros I thought it
was hilarious dude
I did my part
I'm not homophobic two tickets Please
here's my copy of the vote against Prop
8 or whatever the one was to legalize
all those years ago
everybody everybody
I'm here everyone look at me I have
tolerant and accepted
no I loved it I thought I thought it was
a really funny movie I actually wouldn't
say there are Parts about it I loved I
wouldn't say I love nah it was a really
fun I'm careful now it was actually a
really strong it is definitely
um
it is a strong combination of Judd
apatel meets the parts of Billy Eichner
I like and I don't know actually it can
be kind of kind of harder for me
sometimes and I know a lot of people
don't like Billy Eichner generally and
and and I don't agree with the
uh with the way the marketing went down
especially post of like I'm sure there
are those people out there who are like
what trust me
I go to the sauna
and you hear a lot here every time
like I don't got a problem with gay
people just you know
yeah I'm not racist but here's some
racist ideas for you um and so yeah I
like you see even in even in like
liberal L.A you still you see a lot of
it yeah
um so yeah I'm sure there is but I I
don't I think I think it was a poor
handle in a marketing and I feel like
Billy lectures probably not the leading
man you would imagine and and and like
the trailers weren't even like that
funny to me but the movie itself I
thought was surprisingly very touching
cool
um and very funny too it was really fun
I thought it was really funny I I there
were there's one scene in that movie
uh that I was I I yeah I was dying of
laugh the laughter there's one I could
think about it and and I was I could not
it was hilarious it was a really really
funny movie but if you are one of the
people who does scream at guys getting
it on
um like don't nobody no I don't know we
don't know anybody like that don't don't
watch it all right this is like you will
not probably be able to enjoy your time
there Jalen Lugo is funny recommending
peaky blinders that show is is among the
most endured like it's funny like it
seems like one of many many shows out
there in a certain vein I see the the
stuff around it I'm like okay cool I'm
familiar with this kind of thing and yet
it is seemingly the one that like for
years now everyone's just like peaky
blinders man so good you gotta check it
out that's and uh I gotta watch Sons of
Anarchy Ethan Williams thank you for the
Super Chat my friend Ethan dude okay
this is I think with the reject Nation
we are in sync everything everywhere all
at once I've seen so many people saying
this and it's ours too definitely number
one of the Year love you guys and great
work on the channel thank you Ethan
Williams
that is a beautiful ass movie and I'm
really excited to see them win some
stuff hopefully I am not forgotten about
the last of us I know some people who
saw it and they are raving about it and
as a massive fan of the video game I
said oh I am so excited
um thank God they did not make it into
Uncharted
[Laughter]
who was saying that they wanted they
wanted to make it sexier more World War
Z and I'm like thank God World War Z is
four
um yeah I I uh Uncharted to me was about
as Bland of an execution as I know some
people had had fun had a fun with the
movie that's fine for me I really
I really cannot do Uncharted uh I've I
don't want to re-watch it and I don't
either I wasn't like pissed at the film
but I was like man you just have to
really
a movie like that mainly comes down to
tone for me and and pacing and spirit
you know more than anything else I could
readjust to Tom Holland doing Tom
hollandish I couldn't even readjust to
Mark Wahlberg being Mark Wahlberg I like
both of them and I like their General
personalities that they put out to the
public so I could easily have adjusted
and and separate myself from the
characters uh but I did and it's Reuben
Fleischer whose films i i i quite enjoy
and I I could not do it I like I was I
was really bored like really bored yeah
the the Troublesome thing about
Uncharted is that I parts of it are
boring there was stuff at least for me
that in the moment I'm like okay I'm
having kind of a good bad time with this
but like it's it's such that like the
good parts are fine and the bad it's bad
enough at what it's trying to do that
like even though the immediate
experience was like semi-okay Pleasant
I'm like this leaves a a deteriorating
taste in my mouth and there are a lot
more movies like there are a lot of
movies I wouldn't put on but if they
were on I would be like I'll meme watch
this and I feel like Uncharted I
wouldn't even really mean one no I would
I would easily click onto some other bad
movie first I don't think it's terrible
it's fine it's fine I think I think it
like literally is it's fine it's fine
it's fine and you might have fun the
first time you watch it yeah and then
yeah because because the nail in the
coffin is it's fine at being whatever
it's being but it's bad at being what
it's supposed to be yeah you know and
that's a bummer and then you look at
everyone involved and you just get more
and more frustrated I have heard of
Kaleidoscope that does sound like an
interest that you can watch at any
episode it's a it sounds like an
interesting experience oh yeah I would
love to see something like that Avatar
2. go back up for a second somebody said
something something interesting
oh that's all Clements you're welcome
for the Brooklyn 99 videos I I have not
I'm watching The Neil deGrasse version
of uh Neil debt ass that's Cosmos right
now well actually Tyson it's your
favorite streaming service I still think
it's Netflix man I love when people rank
streaming service it's still my favorite
I I think Netflix is the most reliable
one
yeah I think they like [ __ ]
sometimes when they're like top 10
movies watching by the world right now
are our movies yeah our Netflix
originals that none of your friends are
talking about yeah about but everybody
outside of where you are is watching
those movies like really this movie
right now this came out like two days
ago people are watching that six
underground boy everyone loves it but
they are reliable if if I I believe it
when it's not a Netflix original
and that is uh that's like in the top
ten of shows or movies like that seems
authentic yes but I think they do push
like their their original as they as
they that makes sense as much as Netflix
has been a bit of disarray lately they
still do keep coming out you know
however spotty their record they still
keep coming out with great TV and movies
here and there that's where Sharon's
gonna bite Us in the ass it is it is and
and also these are are already pretty
much the new version of cable channels
where it's like you gotta package these
things up or something not everybody
wants to modularly pay for you know a
bunch of things at once but yeah Netflix
I I feel like Hulu is the one I use the
second most because I I guess I've been
watching a lot of FX stuff and then uh
and they got King of the Hill Paramount
plus is surprisingly really people be
loving on periodically good movies on
Paramount plus yeah a lot of good movies
I would have to check it out to rank it
I think actually Amazon would be my
favorite because you kind of get
everything
Amazon is the hack yeah because you
could pay for anything but also
something it's a good price too to pay
for usually it's like a like two bucks
yeah Netflix maybe Amazon Hulu uh I'll
throw HBO Max maybe Disney Disney Plus
for when you need Disney [ __ ]
um but yeah uh Mars eight Productions
thank you for the Super Chat werewolf by
night was a great Chance by Marvel love
those do-more special presentations the
love it got it wouldn't yeah we're gonna
need to work I know we're really behind
on them
um I know it's I know how behind me are
because this was a four this was 45
minutes ago we were talking about this
again uh yes Robert Eggers I still got
to see the lighthouse
yeah man doing reaction really what I'll
eat some beans during the reaction it'll
be good do it in black and white Go full
arts and I'll do it in four by three
yeah
[Laughter]
make it the most annoying thing to look
at yeah like this was funny for an intro
but not for an entire video don't worry
I'll make a separate uh uh stream along
cut where you can sync up and watch it
with film Grant kind of like we did for
werewolf by nine I'll do that trashy
Angie thank you trashy Angie love the
name my dear
hey it's the vacuum
yeah dude Hunter love out in the world
2022 was a great EFM movies my top five
are probably nope X gonna give it to you
I really want to watch x that and uh
Pearl onion what's that movie called
X and pearl yes
mystery I thought there was another word
there I do want to watch those two Score
says you wrote like a letter to a24 the
director of pearl after watching to Thai
West yeah like your movie was good I
need to redeem your cinematic standing
after everyone trolled you for your
Sight and Sound top 10. I wanna I really
want to watch uh I do to yeah let's get
that porn horror movie Up on YouTube
it's gonna be
there's a way to do it just massively
blur upset people I think now people
should get it because there are
YouTubers extremely much more popular
than us in every regard who are
constantly like my [ __ ] videos
and it's good I think actually funny
enough as much as it I love you know
filmmaking and Gore and all that stuff
uh but there are people who can't watch
it who have a hard time watching it
absolutely there are people who have a
hard time watching it and and it only
improves your case for fair use yeah
because I've I've blurred this thing out
like here's some context but people only
yeah it's like so you feel like the
thing is there but you're not seeing
like yeah it's better first
dude yeah where's blur some images
Chandler's list was the hardest it was
one of the hardest ones to edit uh that
was that was really hard at it and uh
yeah because you're also not only do you
have context too yeah and the real life
context and then yeah you just have all
these colliding Visual and thematic
issues that just create a whole other
conversation like gory is easy because
he's blur the gore sure but I'm like I
got so many like words and content words
occasional like you know uncomfortable
non-sexual but still nudity like yeah
there's there's all sorts of harsh
elements Chris Donahue thank you for
this other quick who do you want to see
in the third knives that movie and
Andrew Garfield seems like a great fan
of that University yeah John Cena I
think you gotta be like honor day armors
and he has to work yeah
and uh and who else and uh and bring
back who's in uh in uh no time to die
just bring her in for for shits and
games yeah make it happen yeah Elizabeth
to Vicki it's the other one or is it
Elizabeth yeah I got her confused with
the other blonde lady
I don't know I forget dude oh that would
be a great yeah yeah Gwendolyn Christy
would be good Gwendolyn Christy would be
great yes and uh uh Barry kogan
I did see banshees of insurance oh it
was a good insurance insurance
I don't know the pronunciation it's in a
Sheeran or anything I did see that this
is how we fall behind on the chat so
much I'm sorry guys I'll answer this
thank you Christine we must accept for
upcoming from the MCU in this year yes
yeah yeah I watched it the other day
that was that was a really that's a
great movie I once saw one of his plays
at the Ahmanson and Chris Pine was the
star oh nice you look decrepit um no but
I saw the uh but it but yeah I think um
that's a good movie we'll go into that a
little bit um it's one of my top 10. uh
but most excited for the MCU I would say
is uh
uh I I I'm Gonna Keep the most generic
[ __ ] answer
pull up this I want to see I can't wait
for adventure secret horse man yeah
that's good that is that feels like the
next the next really new moment it
sounds like chaos I I want to see how
they pull it off
I want to see Avengers Secret Wars and
Deadpool 3 that I know those are about
as generic of answers as they get oh is
Deadpool 3 still 2023 is it still in
there well the question is for most
excited for your upcoming okay it is he
doesn't specify 2023. damn all right
fine
foreign
MCU 2023
yeah uh
uh John pick an oddball Tom wants to
watch Agatha House of Harkins maybe I
mean I'll definitely I'm happy it has
iron heart is number one that's right uh
phase I need to see the phase five and
six Graphics there's so much coming and
I feel like there's something that was
like tailor-made for me but now I don't
really have it on the Dome if I had Elon
Musk money I would produce the films
that didn't get made
and it would just be like movie yeah buy
back girl I I I did Spider-Man 4 would
and uh I'd do the Superman Reborn the
Superman Nicolas Cage movie that's what
I would do Mike with my billions of
dollars instead of Twitter do that do
every Nicholas Cage movie that was gonna
at some point that my version is I will
make all the Nicholas Cage Superman
Nicholas Cage Constantine Nicholas Cage
this and that I guess it would have to I
mean if it's not Secret in you say
secret Wars
I said uh secret voice yeah okay I'll go
secret Invasion no oh I know what my
answer is stupid idiot face easily Loki
season two I am very very very excited
for Loki season 2. I'm gonna watch it
from a computer this time I know we're
gonna watch this TV the OLED I'm here
for that like Mobius like like
legitimately I'm very excited for
Ant-Man 3 actually I I think secret
Invasion will be very cool I'm really
excited to see the stylistic thing that
that becomes but Secret Wars crossovers
Galore yeah I know I know I know it but
Secret you'll probably have at least
some of that too let's see you'll have
the the the story but with your
crossovers too sometimes I'll be driving
and I'll just think about
when cap lifted that hammer yeah
it's great that is one of the greatest
moments one of the cinemas yeah
what
just do you remember like the the How
would how could you possibly explain the
generations from now just how how much
of a payoff that way this is so good so
good because that's such great
filmmaking because you see the hammer
lifting and you see it and you're like
you're just a stupid store like you're
not even thinking it's cap no stupid
it's so gratifying stores held down in
that moment if Thor's trying to get that
hammer yeah playing on the audience of
Thor struggling to get the hammer right
now that's why it's having a hard time
lifting yeah yeah no it's just like do I
go to other words
you're like of course he has it's the
perfect convergence of it it's a full-on
perfect moment perfect but it's also
fully dramatically satisfying and
warranted and oh yeah easily one of the
best like pop culture but also Cinema
crossover moments rrr
um yes film of all time I would put it
in top ten have not seen it best film of
all time it's like uh I think it's my
number eight I'm trying to remember my
list here it's eight or nine there's no
movie like it that you will watch all
year and I and out of the respect for
also being a movie that managed to be an
International Film for us International
Film here that became this worldwide
sensation and then you experience it and
it's so much more than just
a like this one thing I really talked
about in a review it's it's so much more
than just a crazy film
it's an actual story and I didn't
realize it was based on a true story
but they still take imagine the teacher
could have to be taking their career
but they uh that they told I thought
they made something that was actually
really nuanced and heartfelt and wildly
creative and it was it was it's it's an
experience like it is a it is a film you
experience and I I thought it was I
thought it was really entertaining and
the performances from those two guys
were so awesome like their chemistry was
off the charts there's a screening I
think in in January it's like the ninth
or something where it'll be like the
first American appearance by I think the
director and stars or something like
that oh no he's very tempted to go also
good call on Andrew Garfield Knives Out
up there I think that would be a cool
ass addition Mark Leach oh Mark Leach
hate to say it man is one of my worst
movies of the year for sure it's all
five of my top five I know Halloween
ends was your top film of 2022. why the
winky face there's no irony here what's
your predictions for what could be both
your fave and worst 2023 or biggest
disappointment ooh let me just take a
second to say that Halloween ends I
thought was one of the biggest
disappointments and I think I think
people who watch real rejects more
people like it than don't than don't
actually and I have sat down with think
pieces videos I love video essays that
really um
explain why they love this film and and
I I take it in and I I completely I am
not so I've made the decision
that like I actually really get why
people by people who like it like it and
I don't sit there with my arms cross and
like whatever you [ __ ] want like I'm
not that guy about it thank you for not
judging me yeah yeah I know you're
allowed to like a movie
it was one of
movies where afterwards I was like this
seems like this could you know be one of
those that makes people think of you a
different way
I think you question your Cinema uh I
spent most of the movie going
what this is weird and I don't I I
didn't like what they focused on I
wasn't a bit that huge fan of the acting
and then by the time it got to the but
for the time that guy takes down Michael
Myers I was like there's some silly [ __ ]
in there and [ __ ] man that's a bunch
of [ __ ]
and people talk about that final fight
being like massively epic and I'm like
kind of it's so short-lived and Michael
Myers getting his ass whoops I want to
spoil it for everyone but in the moment
work hard I wasn't like oh it was like
that of a [ __ ] in this movie Michael
Myers I think a lot of that movie can be
summed up in that moment where Corey
tries to get the mask from Michael and
initially Michael like handily just
throws him in one motion down onto the
ground and you're like yeah Michael
that's Michael and then moments later
Corey gets back up and actually does
manage to take the mask so like I feel
like my enjoyment of that movie though I
enjoyed it more than you it's one of
those movies this year where I'm like
every opinion I've heard is kind of
correct like even though I like the
movie more than I didn't there's still
I was either enjoying it for real or
enjoying it ironically and there's a
good amount of both I think so I don't
think it's I don't love it the way
people who really like it do for being
like as good of a film as they see it as
and they try to like Elevate I got what
they were saying when there was like a
pandemic influence like the evil is the
pandemic and uh yeah like that that yeah
that lingering influence on a Town
that's experienced such trauma I didn't
really think they full fully went there
they try to have something that was like
an Insidious thing in the shadows that
did not really
it's I felt like the movie was at odds
with itself with wanting to be a
Halloween three in this Trilogy and
wanted to do something they just really
wanted to do on their own I feel like
they didn't properly marry them both you
know what really lost me because you did
a whole video yeah with the spoiler talk
and you really really you've watched
that video with John and Andrew they had
a great reaction and a great discussion
um what where it really it lost me so
early on with Laurie Strode that's what
I remembered I'm trying to go off memory
here it was it was I just did not
believe this person
who is spent decades and is now in their
senior years and or the last movie ended
off with her daughter being murdered
would have a couple of years of therapy
and then be like
you know what I'm cool with this guy
living out there he didn't find his body
and look at me I'm happy
yeah I I didn't I could not believe that
interpretation of I I didn't buy it uh
whatsoever and I'm someone who's a big
Champion for therapy and all that and
I'm like that would take like [ __ ]
like two years
yeah you've spent 70 years up until this
point this character would probably hate
a therapist and and not especially with
their daughter being murdered would
motivate them that much more
and as someone who is part of the camp
that enjoys Halloween kills I was like
that should to me
it is one of those things where I had a
very difficult time accepting
the different story they wanted to tell
because I felt like a completely Undead
there are really powerful Cliffhanger
from the last one minus Lori's turn
sorry we're not answering your question
we are now talking about Halloween ends
is one of the worst films
I'll wrap it up yeah yeah minus Lori's
turn like I feel like Halloween ends
would have worked better as the second
installment because then you could have
the whole evil virus then infect the
town evil guys tonight have Halloween
kills be the the ending Capper I don't
know yeah I I like it for doing the
Imposter sequel without actually doing
the Imposter Sequel and a bunch of other
things but yes it's neither the best for
me nor the worst of 2022 it's just
notable I've really thought that if they
just had one scene with Lori in therapy
where you see that she's actually not at
peace and she's really struggling like
she's pretty she's putting she's trying
to put her incentives but weirdly the
last two films turned more into Rob
Zombie films than than one would expect
for as much hate as those get eyes
that's been the best part of the
experience for me everybody comes back
from Halloween kills and as talk about
Rob Zombie a good light and I'm like
What's Up Guys Welcome to My Island with
all the crap Halloween ends was getting
upon release yeah because it had that
wave where it got released and everyone
hated it and because everyone hated it
then all the Defenders came to rise from
the ground you know and that's the best
that's what happens with these movies
and and uh and everyone on Twitter was
like well who would have thought Rob
Zombie's Halloween gotta apologize to
Rob Zombie at least his Michael Myers
wasn't a [ __ ] hey no I mean it's
Michael Myers is the most ferocious one
have not seen Northman would want to
react to it
um for the next year I mean last of us
is my easily my most centered weirdly
it's January less what's my most
anticipated thing I was gonna say as per
the other question do you think anything
will do you have any predictions for uh
things that will surprise Delight or
disappoint you I don't know enough about
what's truly coming to other than like
the popular [ __ ] uh there there are
things that I'm not fully aware of
that's fair enough that's fair enough we
will check out peaky blinders one day
Wyatt's rotout overall what did you guys
think of Hot D I really love how this
show and I'm very excited for season two
how about you guys I am extremely
excited for season two of House of the
Dragon yeah that was one of those shows
that greatly surprised me it was another
one I wasn't that interested in we
didn't even really watch the trailers
for it and then after the first episode
it was that thing of
I'll be honest something special here
it's they might have captured Lightning
Back in the bottle they might know what
they're doing yeah and and I I I think I
as someone who generally is not a big
fan of massive time jumps and shows yes
I I was pleasantly surprised by how well
it worked and I thought it was very
gripping and it ends on a way that you
will not forget that uh I'm excited to
re-watch it in its entirety in a binge
by the Time season two rolls around yeah
it does not make me still doesn't make
me excited for like a Jon Snow show but
this was wonderful yeah and it was
another kind of interesting poll
experience between this and and rings of
power but yeah like House of the Dragon
was one of the year's nicest surprises
and also one of its most Illuminating
examples of how to do some stuff and
even though I feel like book fans are I
feel like how's the dragon is more
agreeable for people than the end couple
seasons of Game of Thrones are for
people but at the same time like the
division makes me curious for the future
because it seems like yeah just as TV
isolated in a bubble it is killing it
and I'm so happy for them but also I
would love to see how the show
progresses and if they can bring then
the book fans like really back into the
love
but yeah it was it was a really
gratifying like especially like shouts
out to both Emma DRC and Millie Alcock
for like everything with the renera too
yeah man I was on the edge of my seat
with that [ __ ] that was one of those
shows that when we were reacting to it I
would think about it throughout the week
yeah totally absolutely and and even
going back to interviews and stuff yeah
because I was really I was really into
that yeah their chemistry and and even
the breakdowns were like super fun to
get back into and like yeah let's really
understand the world of Westeros yeah
and watching heavy spoilers get rich
it's great yeah dude watching him Trend
every day I think we're uh I think we're
blocking our faces off a little bit here
Joe yeah there we go They're gonna be
mine I think we're not mindful enough I
mean
if we want to tempt the feet no no no
we're way too behind you yes on our
tangents Colin Ramirez we all be
watching Barbie in the theater review
streaming service well you know Harvey I
will be playing with our Barbies I want
to
I want to watch it in the theaters but I
also really want to do a reaction
I think we're gonna I'm probably
offering to wait but it would pain me if
it doesn't do well in the theaters to
have contributed to a big contributions
to buy a ticket I might write it off I
might just buy a ticket and not go watch
it yeah yeah yeah
uh yeah I I especially the conversation
surrounding Margot Robbie yes
um yeah
jabby oh he's getting a chance to plug
himself here at any moment in the you
know let me make this about me
how do I plug myself here nobody watched
the north men on get jabby
uh thank you marsay Productions really
really sweet of you go watch Better Call
Saul White Lotus you know everyone
flipping loves that show I've seen a
image of it I don't know what it is I've
seen a couple images and that's it but
it's like it's craving salt and vinegar
chips but yes oh goody sounds dude throw
a little sour cream and cheddar in there
too good yeah uh barbecue chips in there
yeah
queso like barbecue those richest ones
and ones without ridges there you go
White Lotus though if you go to the
grocery store and get a carton
some pretzels wind up in their hair you
know we'll take it as they come
like it's a it's a Mike White joint it
takes place at like each season is
anthological I think so it's like a not
horror but yeah it's like different
Ensemble a couple recurring players
always at some kind of resort and always
sort of dissecting the messed up I think
there's always a murder mystery element
and then you're dissecting Society
through the different characters
basically but I've heard it sounds fun
non-stop talk about how good it is also
you shouted out Atlanta in that comment
I've still got to see season four but
season three was legitimate I have heard
moonfall was uh awful I wanted I want to
watch moonfall and I want to watch
ambulance I want to watch them both
Emerick I think makes consistently
entertaining bad films he does and I
think he's not concerned with pretension
I don't care yes he makes bad films and
they are very entertaining sure and I
like White House Down more than Olympus
Has Fallen sure I agree with that and
Roland emmerich makes the Michael Bay
film you don't feel like you need to
take a bath afterwards for you know he's
like the the more agreeable version of
that we will consider the originals
thank you Joseph Butch thanks for the um
Super Chat Joseph butts did you guys
watch Dahmer I have successfully watched
all of Dahmer oh well done what's your
what's your capsule review
I think that uh it was a little
over hyped I wouldn't call it it becomes
gripping I was more into it
when maybe I've seen just too many
serial killer things by this point
I didn't
feel like I don't want to be like a
Negative Nancy about this show I mean
obviously the performances are amazing I
I was actually kind of surprised by how
much they withheld on the actual Gore
like you would see a lot of the lead up
and you would see some of the after but
I think that was the part where they
were probably the most respectful was
you wouldn't see too much of the actual
Gore because he did some like really
horrendous disgusting things yeah was
not a good dude all right it does it
does take some of that approach though
where you're like I'm finding myself
feeling a little bad for this guy
I don't want to feel any sympathy for
you yeah uh because it because it in its
attempt to do the um deconstruct I could
see it's a fun show I imagine to debate
about uh okay I think Richard Jenkins
was amazing
dude I think he deserves an Emmy
nomination for it for sure and I feel
like he won't but I don't think he
deserves it I liked all the stuff after
he was caught they'd do a good amount of
focus there
and it does it it had an interesting
thing because there's one and one later
on in the series they they do say
as I think it is an important thing to
talk because it was such a big part of
the discussion leading up to it of they
wanted to be respectful to the victims
they kept saying that we want to be sure
yeah and I'm like I don't know man I'm
really I'm really into Jeffrey Dahmer
I'm feeling like I really feel bad I
suffer like this guy
I don't think it does that like I I
funny enough don't find it to be like
American Horror Stories Jeffrey Dahmer
or or like this exploit it's not a fun
show because you could hear how it could
go that way yeah and I thought that's
what I was walking into uh it's not a
slow it's a slow deliberate Moody
atmospheric piece and um if anything
it's like Ryan Murphy's influence trying
to be mine hunter in a way and uh and
and there was this one part in later on
where the victims are watching
Jeffrey Dahmer become this television
sensation on the front cover of People
magazine and they're cutting around to
the victim's reactions to it
and they're like why is he getting
all this attention and stuff and we're
not getting any like help and everything
and and and what I when I was like well
this Show's kind of a hypocrite
because I just spent like seven straight
episodes watching nothing but Jeffrey
Dahmer and really understanding him and
the show making him more famous than
ever they moved the goal post one yard
further they have this sentence here
that's trying to say like we shouldn't
sensationalize Jeffrey Dahmer I'm like
but you are just regardless of whatever
uh attempt you're having I think your
your execution here is but I'd be lying
if I said I wasn't gripped uh in the
latter half I I was really I wanted to
finish it I found myself itching to
continue it
um it wasn't a chore it was I found
myself really uh I was engaged and and I
really I think the last I enjoyed the
last half more than the first half and
uh I really I thought it was really well
acted well a well-directed experience
and uh it did get me curious to at least
respect the fact that a lot of I mean
they take definitely creative Liberties
or characters I'm like there's like one
character in particular who gets a lot
of focus is one of the victims who lived
next door to Jeffrey Dahmer but so much
of Hiroshi is is not true at all yeah I
I didn't know that I was like oh she has
to be the most real one like oh never
mind she's she's really slammed they
slammed a bunch of things together and
then a lot is not true yeah
but but she's great in the show though
regardless this is the point where I
believed her anyway
but yeah I could see why the show was a
big hit because you know serial killer
and all that and we all are drawn to it
is Evan Peters Still The King
yeah I still think to me I think he's
still I would like to see him Branch out
from [ __ ] to Psychopaths is seven
Peter's gonna be okay that's the number
one thing I've heard people say is is
please and I think he has even said this
like please let him play a normal dude
in something whatever's next well I mean
he could do stuff like American animals
or it's not like a like a psycho you
know yeah even though it's a real life
guy but not yeah quite as like holy [ __ ]
you gotta really risk your psyche to do
this role to me he's still
um I still consider him like what we all
Associated Johnny Depp as in his younger
years sure now uh he reminds me so much
of that I cannot wait for his nasty
divorce trial 20 years down the line
Eminem
oh no you just need a good poop pun for
that
John shout out Chad Chad dirkowitz have
you done a spoiler video of Avatar we
have not I finally watched it yesterday
and I gotta see your spoiler review of
it
compelled to do it let's do a 10 hour
spoiler review live stream is there a
spoiler in Avatar most people have seen
it is there something here that you've
that really
stood out to you is there no like
shocking reveals really it's I feel like
yeah I mean there are like intimate
story details you can talk about but the
story itself is still Universal enough
where I feel like knowing
it would be stuff like like oh he lets
courage live you know and and the kid
rescues him and he's going to go off for
part three like I guess that could be a
spoiler alert
uh but for the most part it's like of
course they're gonna make it through and
they're gonna bond with the river people
and you know it's gonna be a beautiful
dazzling Masterpiece of technological
advancement and they're gonna have to
you know save the ecological the
ecosystem from you know the the march of
colonization you know like I feel like
it's more of a thematic movie and then
just talking about like oh this moment
was great or that moment was great but I
don't know I like the uh I like parent
Revenge
[ __ ] if only Jake and natiri had shoved
his head in the microwave man like that
Last House on the Left effect when they
uh when they when it's time for them to
like work together I'm like oh that's
cool or like the Patriot if you guys can
I see the Patriot Mel Gibson in the
woods
have you seen the Patriot no what no oh
Fourth of July reaction every movie you
have on your list Josh you are reacting
to the Patriot let me pull up that list
oh and it's a ruling Emerick film it is
very fictional but it is
oh man you haven't seen the Patriot and
and none of the Lethal Weapon movies and
none of the Muppet movies start with uh
start with the Patriots okay
Warren westerns number one screw your
categories you have here just put
Patriot as uh one big page okay copy and
paste that word
every category Patriot oh that movie's
so good it is apparently I'm excited to
see it I'm not a child
so good oh yeah Heath Ledger he's Ledger
there's so many Heath Ledger joints I've
never seen 10 Things I Hate About You
and knight's tail Knight Styles good
yeah John probably has more of the
movies that would I've kind of gone
through I'm like looking through my list
of like 40 moves I'm like kind of done
all the big ones I've still got some big
ones that I feel like oh let's try on
like a little play trains on automobiles
I haven't seen most of like the biggest
I feel like a a run of romantic comedies
could be fun maybe if those are I don't
know I love romantic comedies dude I've
never seen a lot of the classics
um
this isn't happening anymore brick man
Mosaic I don't think they're going to do
the Margot Robbie joint no of part
Security in Shadow Ash 21. hey thanks to
the Super Chat I been a fan of yours for
a long time question do you think Venom
2 should have been rated all that uh
that wasn't this year right no no
because it was before morbius yeah yeah
I mean it did have car engine he's done
some twisted stuff in the comics uh yeah
I thought uh it absolutely should have
been rated R i i i i i i that movie has
not grown on me I'll say that it has not
grown on me in Spider-Man no way home
did not help it get better
it made him feel less important even
though my favorite rapper or one of my
favorite rappers appeared in it I don't
really have any reason to go go check
out the new little Sims she's great but
uh but yeah Venom 2 is a there's nothing
of the charm that stuck in my mouth
whereas I still think back to the first
Venom and I was like oh man him and
Eddie were fun you know
uh rings of power uh Chase Gardner well
I'm glad you loved rings of power I did
not
it does not make me super jazzed about
season two
um you know Cosmonaut variety hour did a
great video on the Lord of the Rings
trilogy if you guys haven't seen you
should listen you should go watch it
it's a great editor too I believe he
edits his own videos fantastic editor
um uh
for some reason I whenever I flash the
rings of power like those lord of rings
are just too good
um and they're too good at being what
they are and the thing is as beautiful
as rings of power often does look I feel
like it still has more of a computery
Sheen than the Lord of the Rings does
and does they shoot that on film
Lord of the Rings I don't think there's
films yeah like the movies uh yes damn
that would be hard
so much film yeah you had so much films
Peter Jackson
yeah and and you need to know to a
certain degree like they have obviously
all the budget but you need to know what
you need and how to get it in fact I was
watching I was watching something that I
can't really talk
it's not high stakes but I can't talk
too much about but there was a piece of
advice in it that was like you know for
for a filmmaker you what you need to
know the secret Juju is
you need to know what you need how to
get it
but the extra ounce of JuJu is you need
to know when you got it and when to move
on and I feel like film necessitates
that because then you look at something
like The Hobbit and Peter Jackson is
very transparent by like I was winging
it man and like that's a movie that
needed to be shot on a digital camera uh
but yes the movies were filmed yeah
there's a lot of benefits to shooting on
digital though with the for actors I
think I think there's a lot of pros and
cons tons like film looks better to me
but film makes anything look like a
movie and that's the thing is like if
you look at uh it was my example weirdly
is even though I haven't seen a million
of them as like trauma movies or any old
like look at any old crappy low budget
movie and now look at a crappy low
budget movie today and the difference
between like film will make it look like
a real movie no matter how cheap it is
whereas digital will not do that uh
let's see here uh I would love okay yeah
rings of power I think they have room to
improve and if they take constructive
criticism it could be good I think rings
of power is a show that I overall liked
yet I would still categorize it as one
of the biggest disappointments of the
year yeah because you have to try your
way through the whole thing you have to
exert so much effort you have to bend so
many different ways to be like there's
good stuff in here there is a potential
that I liked to be like all right you
got me but damn there were some there
were some there were some episodes there
that were really hard that were me not
great that was very very you know I
would try and I'm like I can't do this
is but then it would suddenly have
something I'm like that was great like
they did it it was kind of it was such a
weird experience for me yeah everything
was good by it relatively good but not
just like maybe one episode or so or
certain moments but yeah nothing like a
slam dunk where you're like now we're on
point now we're on the the cruising
altitude Michael Mack thank you Michael
Mack Michael mock that's the most
underrated show for me was the bear
you're here that episode they did in one
take was masterful one take episode of
Television oh that sounds so stressful
I'm so excited
the show is it's a stressful show they
get they do really well at capturing the
like chaos of so many people in a room
working towards the common goal uh the
Batman and gotta watch Barbarian later
Big Love from Scotland
three guys hi well um I will say that
the Banshees of isherin isherin initial
yeah in a Sheeran something like that
but yeah there's he did uh
okay so I mean the first one I saw was
uh In Bruges I saw three Billboards
outside of Missouri Epping Missouri and
then Seven Psychopaths Campus before
that I haven't seen that either yeah but
the bash is which is on HBO Max right
now
is a beautiful looking movie first off
with these incredible natural
performances
that and oh and I'm actually guilty of
not being that knowledgeable about Barry
keogan's work and he's creating it too
he's a full-on Irish guy they all are
and uh
it's it do you know what it's about yes
I do I know the premise yeah the premise
is it takes place in 1930s Ireland
there's literally like a civil war
happening across the island which is
like a backdrop metaphor it was placed
throughout the film and and then um you
know uh Colin Farrell he he wants one
day is his best friend Gleason just
decides he doesn't want to be his best
friend anymore and it becomes like the
success I heard the premise and I was
worried that this will become our real
life yeah
and then Colin Farrell's just working
his ass off to get his friend back right
yeah yeah he's working his ass off and
then Brandon galise is doing whatever he
can to keep him away and and it's and
it's uh it gets dark but I I really uh
I was impressed with how authentic I
don't know what an authentic Irish
language is like but uh it sounded
authentic and the acting is great and
it's really this interesting film about
uh in some ways toxic masculinity but
really about the importance of
understanding your emotions at a deeper
level and communicating it really is
about communication more than anything
else and I I was surprised by it it was
one of those movies I was like after it
was done
I was like yeah I liked it and then the
more then I kept thinking about it and
the more I'd reflect on it the more I'm
like no that's a that's a great film
that's a really good and it's funny too
there's some funny ass [ __ ] there's some
funny ass moments well and especially
because there there are certain like
it's like number 10 on my tent okay yeah
and what I'm excited to see especially
Martin McDonough return to like I liked
three Billboards and I've heard just our
spot John I am so sorry what did you do
you put up a freaking poll and now we
lost it all I've heard and no I I know
where to go I know where to go uh it's
nice to see because I know some people
didn't love uh three Billboards partly
because of the fact that uh it's not as
lived in in terms of its setting like
Donna doesn't know this you know the
American South as well as he knows
Ireland and so I'm excited to see him
return to a place that he really knows
how to write from uh because especially
having seen yeah like a couple of those
plays in there of his like you know
there's some magic that happens when
Irish eyes are smiling
how far back did you set us Don it's
okay I got us
how far back
now we have to put away the chat I also
play catch up on Super Chat I also got a
uh sending out some love I saw somebody
said another rip short should donate rip
loss of spookies absolutely rip lots of
spookies we talked about every movie in
the thumbnail at least once right oh
very much so yeah we covered actually a
lot of them very early on Jurassic world
Dominion had no idea what to do with its
new cast or old cast
yeah that's yup in fact the best
characters to me were ones introduced
solely in that movie like the the pilot
lady is is like the best character in
that movie and everybody else and and
I'll give it to Bryce Dallas Howard she
was there she showed up okay dude here
we go Jason DeLong
hope you guys
thank you by the way have a great 2023.
do you guys think Adam Driver would make
a great Doctor Doom is Everett K Ross as
Doom a meme I heard that rumor too I
personally would love to see Adam's take
on the character
I think every Russ is Dr Doom would be
kind of a
I'm sure they could make it happen it
would be a choice I feel like it's just
so so removed from what Dr Doom is that
I feel like it would be weird I feel
like you would just have a guy in a
doctor Doom's suit but he wouldn't be Dr
Doom
I do not like the idea of Adam Driver
being you don't want to copy kylo Ren
you want to do a copy of kylo Ren it
would be such a it would be like if
Kristoff Waltz played another bad guy
which he undoubtedly will or mads
Nichols or Liam Neeson playing another
badass guy who needs to save a family
it's just like no please don't make Adam
Driver do that uh I I don't like that
get more inspired yeah and weirdly be
okay with it a guy who plays a lot of
villains Javier Bardem doing it then
that would be cool and Adam Driver this
is Adam Driver so much linked to kylo
Ren a dude or a mask with a deep voice
you really want to do that again
it's not worth it's not worth the
potential okay smoothing out of that
experience yeah to yeah distract Us in
this experience always take more of it
Ross though yeah man ever Ross scene
stealer
he is Harps K thank you Harps K Harvest
dude happy New Year fellas Happy New
Year to you second season of Alice in
Borderland on Netflix just snuck in as
one of the best shows I've seen this
year a lot of great things keep hearing
about Alice Borderland it's Japanese
right not Korean oh my God Barry and the
chat someone Josh in the chat pointed
out the show Barry that is how could I
forget about Barry so one episode of
Barry damn is that a good episode
oh that might be my oh God I gotta
re-rank it yeah no it's one of the best
shows uh ever did that last season was
so intense and had some of the best
Direction the Best Direction I think
Barry other than the Ronnie episode the
best direction that uh Bill hader's done
and I'm like his his the way he's
elevated his directing is
like this guy has to make films like
action films
so he's such a great director because he
directed like all the episodes right
they're to most at least and played all
the characters there's some there's some
action scenes in there that I was like
this is funny dark but so cool to look
at I mean and sometimes he gets really
dreamlike and ethereal I really love it
cool um but anyway yeah sorry uh Allison
Borderland
um you know I I didn't know was based on
a manga until recently and the cultural
phenomenon surrounding it makes a lot
more sense but I do want to check it out
it's a Japanese show uh sure it has to
be I think it is yeah I really do want
to see that I've heard nothing but
amazing things
awesome thank you for the recommendation
and uh Ian daginger
I'm going with that thank you for
jumping in never thought I would say
this but I think the new Puss in Boots
movie might be my favorite film this
year thrilled for the new yaw that's a
nice attitude to have especially when to
think just a couple years ago people
remember when it was like 2020 that was
like the worst year for so many people
it seems like the years have only been
bad since 2020. at the end of 2021
everyone's like good written I would be
happy to forget this year ever happened
and especially this year I feel like the
bring on 2023 energy looms large and
everyone's like I wish I could forget 22
so yeah we'll see I hope 2023 is a Good
year blimp
um princess Consuela banana [ __ ] what
about RR to talk extensively about that
talked about some RR and Vishnu Sharma
yeah yeah you haven't once even spoken
to me about RR damn it that's the reason
John has not taken the time if only you
would help me to watch it then I would
watch it immediately I would drive you
say watch it I would just go right now
no I'd heard anyone talk about it it's
my fault he has not watched it I will
hunt down the copy that's in the proper
language and and we'll go yeah
apparently there's the proper language
is not on Netflix and uh I didn't
realize that
um whoa you're going going to miss our
spot online
what are we waiting for no in the line
of here oh it's in the line of change
I'm creating more engagement
we have to this is why we had to pull up
this menu here yeah it's good it's good
it's not good we like people like it
more when the chat is public in the
center all right and now we missed now
we have to oh you've done messed this up
Johnny I'm sorry how could you forget
what happened 10 minutes ago I didn't
forget I just wanted to you just wanted
to make another part of the fun of live
streaming is creating engagements
we are in kitchen
just saw Babylon says he's naturally
Happening by talking specifically about
what they're saying look now we got this
charming bit out of it where are we at
here we've lost the spot and lost 20
viewers thanks John I'm sorry now we got
a wise we got how far up here do we have
to climb
to oh my God
oh you've the create the climbing
process has just increased by
tenfold John I'm sorry it's okay you'll
be punished later I will Public public
why you get time off and I work on our
um let me go I would have happily
watched RR yeah yeah we was giving you
time we had an agreement that it would
give you more time to do other things
random Andy's Channel just saw Babylon
loved it hoodie oh glad to hear that
people love Babylon out there aren't you
like very Christian too I've heard some
stories of like random like very
Christian individuals going to watch
Babylon not realizing what Babylon was
about ends up being something that is
typical story and it is far from it uh
random Manny's Channel thank you so much
uh for the Super Champ being here buddy
hope your your mother is doing good say
hi to your mother for me oh wait no I
think that's a bad comment to make
no no no I'm okay
xandar brow uh
thank you zando bro just saying you guys
inspired me to keep making short films
that being said everything everywhere is
still my favorite movie of the year we
inspired to make sure films we have
another sketch all year are you sure
that was fun you're just watching all
the oldest guys okay whatever it is
maybe you'll Inspire us to make a sketch
now
what are you doing I'm just seeing what
the uh what the other options are in
terms of how the chat uh Works in terms
of uh playback
you know just curious
um okay that's curious oh Courtney Hamer
though thank you Courtney yeah if you
haven't seen it would you all ever
consider watching and reacting to the
White Lotus season two exceeded my
expectations which is unanimous from
everyone I've spoken to love both
seasons so much and I feel like you both
would really enjoy it
uh I mean John just talked about it
about what he knows of it maybe
binge it and then maybe do season three
yeah honestly like there's some some
shows where I'm like I just I I prefer
to if we're like way behind I might just
like and if they have new seasons coming
out then maybe I'll just catch up and
then do it you know because
like uh like working on something like
Wednesday right now that I'm trying we
want to get them all up before last of
us comes out and uh you know like
getting all that done at Eight Episodes
I'm guessing is close to about 30 to 35
hours in total to to fully assemble all
eight so you know that's why
um it's just more of a time thing
um but yeah maybe Mike Joyce if you
start morbius at exactly 10 49 Leto will
say It's morbin Time at exactly midnight
I wish I love this trend I love this
trend that's just somebody post a thing
of uh if you if you start the finale of
Andor at a certain time at midnight
you'll get to watch the the big bell
ringer guy kick the bucket head off the
tower nice but I would love a morbid you
know what tell me what time I have to
start it so that
um that Matt Smith's like sexy dance
happens at midnight that's what I want
from orbius thank you Mike Joyce thank
you Courtney Hammer flick freaks oh
thank you flick freaks
everything that's racist knowing all the
Asian people yes that's that's that's
they trapped us they knew we knew what
they were doing
uh I've never not taken the joke
everything everywhere all at once is the
number one movie of the uh I've only
given 26 movies a perfect 10 out of 10
and this is one what's Wild it's not the
only movie this year to get out of 10
out of 10. women talking is astonishing
another 10 out of 10. I've heard from
damn Earl that that is the most apt
title of the year
[Laughter]
you know what to expect is literally
women talking I heard Sarah Paulie who
is a woman for two hours talking about
women talking the movie She directed
about women talking
and she was talking with at least one
other woman and some dudes about it so
look out I'm gonna do sequel men talking
about women
and it's just like you just drop a
camera in a locker room you just leave
it there hot chicks out there man
dude am I looking small enough to go
back out there Steve G hey guys Happy
New Year's Eve thank you Steve G for
being here with us I enjoy all the
content this year all of it you've seen
every video I've seen every video of it
it's all 40. rank them all what are you
doing man you should be watching 40
videos uh thank you for it what are the
new films of 2023 you are looking
forward to
first one that comes to mind is the show
The Last of Us the second of the movie
I'm looking for the earliest part of the
year I'm the Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania
because I I do think Marvel is in need
of a if a a weirdly it hasn't gone to a
complete divide
I do think they are in need of some type
of springboard for people to feel like
Marvel's back yeah they are in need of
that they do because it dunk because
phase four has had a like while you know
I love wakanda forever and I've defended
Multiverse and Madness that I I'm very
much aware of the overall reception of
phase four
and and especially the latter half of
phase four and and I feel like if
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumina being
the start
for it's phase five if it could be a
springboard more than anything else for
like yes this is the Marvel we've been
wanting back
or or the new direction or the
excitement of Multiverse then I feel
like that would be the best way to go do
you have one John
um films I'm most looking forward to for
2023 I mean it's like it's a lot of
sequels and stuff it's like John Wick uh
the new Saw movie uh I am very excited
to see oh what was that um yeah I don't
know stuff like that uh
the Patriots Patriots the Patriots
John's gonna watch the people first time
I'm excited for Oppenheimer I'm excited
for maybe Christopher Nolan to come back
to like full-on uh you know thoughtful
filmmaker Christopher Nolan doubt it huh
I think he will he kind of has to uh Sam
Bravo oh Donald you're looking real
dude you can look real schmexy too when
you head over to shopzeroedition.com
yeah I appreciate it though I love this
beanie and I like the Pom-Pom too we
differ on the Pom-Pom because I'm not I
don't like the
pom-pomer literally pulled my Pom-Pom
off I noticed that
some people love the pom-poms I was like
making an option yeah yeah um because
it's not like it costs more to produce
um I don't know creatorian thank you
creatorium Happy New Year my suggestion
would be Brendan Fraser as Ben Grimm AKA
The Thing thought uh while I actually
think he would be a great choice for Ben
Grimm he's already doomhead on Doom
Patrol
which is already a thing like adjacent
in a way and uh I that's the main I'm
like ah come on you know
I was more excited for him as Firefly
I'm sad or robbed of that appearance and
Batgirl I was really excited for him as
that rip that girl thank you though
Samuel Michelle
just read thank you for your Super Chat
just for rumors of Cavill joining Marvel
for Captain Britain I mean now is the
time you just read them you haven't
heard them for the past like three three
years yeah yeah yeah um but now is the
time to make it happen I don't know
maybe that maybe Marvel can use that as
their big Ace in the whole of like we'll
get all this Goodwill back
Cavill Secret Wars you just see Black
Adam and Superman decking it out in the
background yeah
yeah and then Shazam swoops in punches
work with him do it be the bridge my
message Rami thoughts on Andrew Tate
love him great individual and I love
doing business with him innocent until
proven guilt yeah definitely bring some
ladies over here I I don't know enough
about honestly some P I got messages uh
about like sure about Andrew Tate when
he got arrested and I was like who's
that again I did it I couldn't recall
who he was yeah I don't really follow
Andrew Tate
um information about him and I'm not
just saying that to try to sound like
cool or something I'm just not plugged
into Andrew Tate news uh and so uh I've
heard people talk about it and I don't
have too much of a thoughts on it it's
like well if he's guilty then good thank
God he's hot it sounds like a horrible
human being if all that's true that's my
thought process on it yeah the moment
was very gratifying I think the fact
that he got caught via a pizza box is
hilarious yeah recording a video to
prove he wasn't bothered by a tweet is
is it's like and and people are like
Greta thundberg took him down and I'm
like I love The Narrative of the story
but but his own stupidity and it yeah
it's brought him down like his own
arrogance yeah for a guy who spews as
much uh you know hate as he does and
apparently brings some real life pain
and suffering into the world good
riddance
yeah I just don't know enough have fun
with that red pill my guy I haven't I
haven't researched into any of it but I
think the story of him you take it down
my pizza is
it's been hilarious I have a smash of
people watching like find out where that
pizza because it's partly too as he gets
handed the pizza boxes and I saw the
video and my first thought was what is
the name on that pizza box what chain
did he order a pizza from
and the QR code like oh it's immaculate
it doesn't look so beautiful doesn't
look like it's a very common place yeah
well it's got like a common name but now
people are it's called like Jerry's
pizza or something if anything they did
promotion for the pizza and then they
even tweeted like Jerry's pizza
delivering Swift Justice I was like damn
everyone is dogging on it like yeah yeah
but uh I I'm not trying to be like in
the middle here or something I just
don't know enough about it and I'm not
gonna I think like the popular opinion
would be like good riddance [ __ ]
but the the honest thing is I don't know
enough about it
um so he's a good guy you should check
him out he's got a lot of great
philosophies following he's following
yeah
um
creatorian
I still have the title song from peace
make that shouts out for best intro of
the Year absolutely Peacemaker
was that this year yeah was it not Am I
Wrong Am I wildly wrong about it when
did you move I don't know it was June
July this year okay so it would have
been this would have been around this
year sure Peacemaker was great that was
Great Peacemaker was awesome oh my God
was Peacemaker this year
not on the list here because that's
easily one of the best of the Year
season one
2022
yeah January 13th it it started in
January so it started like right at the
top of the year and finished in February
so yeah Paul just said
um
I have to sell the channel
[Laughter]
so it's Paul
[Laughter]
is it is it this year it's it aired and
uh it aired January 13th to February
17th of this year yeah 2022.
so damn update all the lists because um
Peacemaker was definitely quality and
Peacemaker was one of those like yeah I
mean of course gonna watch it but also I
thought that it was this year and I'm
kind of blur to me yeah and I'm happy
it's as good as it was this is why you
should have to do research if we're
doing it right yeah [ __ ] best show in my
opinion but I can't forgive gun not to
keep Cavill what a waste oh yeah
Peacemaker was Peacemaker is a welcome
surprise because uh that sounded like a
terrible idea to do a show about
Peacemaker somehow worked off great and
became a big impact and
um was as much crap as The Suicide Squad
gets Peacemaker became a really big show
uh yes and I agree I'm sorry about
sorry about what happened to Henry
Cavill I'm sorry on your back yes
um it's sad it is sad
I do feel bad for the guy
I really do it's weird to feel bad for a
super famous successful guy and swiplash
everybody wanted him to I think
everybody wanted him to bring the
hopeful Superman to life and he wanted
to and now it'll happen someday but not
now Giovanni Alfaro ooh hey I've been
watching all since roast of the reactors
with I'm Dante keep doing your thing
love thank you so much those are the
great days when I'm Dante had barely any
of a following yeah now he's so big now
he's the so big and he's constantly
texting like look how much better I am
than you and more successful it's like
shut up how long does it take my words
to get all the way down there to you
bits
constantly spitting on me always he has
enough money to fly first class to spit
on him yeah dude and then he leaves
he's Harry Styles you all year round so
successful I don't feel successful Barky
Bucky Barnes hey what's up buddy hey bud
are you moderating uh he's in the chat
happy holidays guys late congrats thank
you so much buddy thank you for being a
good guy to help hold down the fort of
these streams Paul stop rubbing it in
man Paul Hollywood what are you doing
man is he doing it is he is he making
you feel like a bad YouTube
foreign
kavanti Kawa would you watch succession
I would watch succession
would that mean we we didn't do this oh
sorry sorry Kai didn't mean to skip over
you Kai thank you Kai
um happy holidays Greg and John and
congrats Greg
yeah look who's messing up the chat now
yes
one second fix same same thing not
exactly a fantasy sci-fi thing but if
you asking the power of myth no that'd
be your jam
why isn't it by the secret lady
is it Rhonda Burton
am I thinking of the wrong thing
sometimes I watch terrible things happen
to people in real life
sentence sometimes I watch terrible
things happen and I go
ah somehow they attracted all that
through life
only to blame themselves through the
power of law of attraction ah the power
of myth is Joseph Campbell there you go
it's uh oh I definitely enjoy that
reveals how the themes and symbols of
ancient uh lore and stuff uh reflect in
art today
um and are we going to react to The
Witcher prequel no we're not going to I
have I shall know in my private time
watch uh read through the reviews
people don't like this show
um but now it's God's Defenders everyone
hated it sure yeah that's the natural
Order of Things No it had like and I
imagine the audience backlash has
something more to do with the fact that
fans were hating the show because of
cousins hey Henry Cavill eating and B
um the fact that they've been changing
so much in the actual show
um I'll tell you what it is the Mighty
Fall with that show I don't think Paul
realizes I'm gonna live stream I notice
he's been blowing you up
bring some of that over into the actual
live stream why don't you it has a 35
critic score 12 audience so yeah it's
pretty bad dude if Paul got in the chat
right now imagine I know we do comment
it's gonna be like
I'm gonna say can you put all these
messages in my live stream
oh yeah yeah yeah do it do it do it
happy New Year Kai
from us to you The Witcher kavante
Caldwell would you watch succession
uh I've seen a couple episodes I want to
watch this that's gonna be a fun one to
watch Dude watch it my favorite
experience right now is showing my wife
Breaking Bad that is a beautiful I feel
like that is one of those TV show
experiences that we all have to look
forward to sharing with somebody and so
like as it just progresses and then [ __ ]
happens
yeah I can't watch this this is too much
why did you tell me this is amazing yeah
that's my favorite dude you know what's
funny is uh I saw Sky High for the first
time this year and the glow in the dark
guy is in succession what would you say
is your favorite movie you've reacted to
this year that I saw for the first time
of like an old older movie oh
time would be everything everywhere
besides that 17 Again
oh really that's weird okay
damn
you know
solo
solar or just any of them
it doesn't matter
it's always Halloween ends no uh you
know one of the most absolute like I'm
trying to get this cat
actually come here funny enough flat
Flashpoint I think was the most fun and
the most sort of like dunk of a
combination of like this movie is
awesome and also like I love the moments
that came out of this reaction itself
um so like as a complete package it
might have uh been Flashpoint I think
was was really pretty great but uh pray
of the live-action ones was super
gratifying
um oh but that's that's the new one this
year uh
God it's hard to narrow them down
because everyone I've done has also been
very different I did like an anime and I
did a prey and then I did uh I've only
done a couple of the solo ones but yeah
um all right
thanks a lot appreciate it
I mean they're all I don't know it's
hard to choose a favorite one this guy
because this one was about you been a
fan oh down free for all run been a fan
since you peaked early that is John's
um High School quarterback that is my
high school quarterback championship
ring right there and as beautiful as a
memory as it is it's also like ah you
know I gotta create a new thing I gotta
get a new thing it's been way too long
and now that show doesn't exist anymore
so now it doesn't mean what it used to
mean
what is that what is a free-for-all what
did you do
um but I appreciate it thank you for
making a good moment Lovelier Jane and
the Autobots thank you so much yeah
this was so out of left field this has
to be one of the best movies I've ever
watched
it I hope to see it nominated for some
stuff RR should definitely get nominated
for some [ __ ] I'd be interested in
foreign film of the year
that seems like the thing to do it's the
most talked about International Film and
everybody seems to agree that it
converges the things you love about a
blockbuster with the things you love
about films in general and storytelling
so yeah I mean I'll never forget being
at a bar and having two tall white guys
oh good telling me you gotta watch rrr
and that's what I was like
this film really has transcended white
two tall white
looking up at
and maybe go wow I guess I should watch
this movie you two probably learned the
newspired me they're white savings for
my experience absolutely vodka they're
doing their part man they're doing their
part they're bearing stranger things for
the bear is great I wanna I'm so excited
to finish it
can you imagine they just dropped the
ball with stranger things five
Jane can you imagine that Jane um I mean
the stakes grow ever higher the stakes
grow ever ever higher I I would it would
be so fun if they just focus solely on
Finn wolfhard
really made up we heard everybody's
complaints about season four so now it's
only Jonathan and Finn wolfhard
and uh
yeah yeah they weren't that important
it's all Argyle plot lines from now on
Emperor's New Groove is really fun I
don't know every every new movie I'm
still on this
it's hard to pick favorites ask if you
flummoxed Me by asking me what my
favorite is it'll work every time
pavenmeier uh is Mr Sunday movies your
favorite channel oh my God wait we're
back we're back are we we're so back
where's povin Meyer it's down below a
Jay wood oh you're right we're back to
the chat back to the chat the lightning
strap freaking yeah time oh I want to
see the woman King I want to see the
woman King dude we should react to it
yeah Viola Davis getting jacked yeah hey
not enough jacked ladies in Hollywood
for things for good reason it's it's
unnatural I tell you they must be on
steroids yeah we allow women into the
gym to use the elliptical machine and
the elliptical machine only let's not
forget to go back to the stream Labs too
let's get these chats right off screen
there we go
all righty Lana from Hawaii she's gotten
people to go to
well I appreciate you being in the
Stream Labs apparently she's got an only
fans that support your local content
creator I I I feel I don't pledge when
he only fans people who do only fans
hustle that's awesome man I know it's
hard work man it takes a lot of it it's
basically it's work it's just sexy
content creation it's like the same nuts
and bolts just with like a different
social conversation around it Happy New
Year to my two favorite dudes on the
internet best wishes 23. well happy
happy New Year to my my favorite only
fan star yeah who you I don't subscribe
to there's good content
it was the best content yes
thank you that's so sweet Doran yes
Tulsa King uh it's surprisingly good
it's no Sopranos but is it's uh uh one
of the best lone flicks in recent years
yeah chainsaw man is also awesome other
underrated show Tokyo Vice cancel Elgort
and Ken Watanabe oh nice it's so bad
that it's good film show Riverdale oh
it's still going happy New Year guys
it's New Year's here in Romania looking
forward to another fun year in cinema
and TV and of course your reaction thank
you I'm one of our best supporters man
and I really appreciate your love thank
you you were a lovely bright ray of
sunshine in our little organization
dude Dumb and Dumber though I just saw
that too man that's crazy I was so what
that was one where I was like I that's
the only one you did
that I wasn't in a video with you that
made that I had a feeling of
I really hope he likes this oh yeah I
did and apparently I know that comedy
wait I know that way too well and uh and
so I was like yeah I really really hope
he likes because I love that movie well
now I I per the comments I guess it was
the extended the the Extended Cut or
like the more jokes cut I guess so yeah
which I thought was still really fun I
was I was worried when
through the process of getting you the
movie
okay I was like I can't I found a phone
I'm like I don't know if it's the
Extended Cut or not I can't really tell
yeah yeah even but either way like
people in the comments were like oh the
theatrical cut is is better and funnier
um but even so like it was one of those
experiences where after so many like I
was curious because it seems like a
prime example of a movie that could
easily lose it could easily age poorly
and uh it didn't like I watched it and
even in the extended version and hearing
people's opinion on that I was like nah
man I get why this is an enduring gross
out you know situation comedy classic
like guys leave a like if you're here by
the way leave a like for Jim Carrey and
Jeff Daniel like they're again the words
have been said but yeah their commitment
to the characters and the charm and the
and the the right amount of stupidity
like yeah it was really nice I enjoyed
it a lot povin Meyer these Mr Sunday
movies your favorite Channel
I want to clear what my favorite channel
is just yet but I will establish that it
publicly that a weekly planet is my
favorite podcast I loved weekly they're
definitely my favorite podcast they're
I've been him and Mason
uh there's there's lots of news they're
perfect they're like per and they're
they're uh every bit of
I think Greg and John would love to be
some American version
I'm sure that's yeah it wasn't somewhere
no I adore them and honestly you know
sometimes if I'm like I can often take
myself
um very serious because there's a lot of
other things take so much focus and like
time and thinking about time and how
much is in the day so it sounds like
it'd be very serious and a lot of times
if I I kind of need to get in the mood
to to loosen up a little bit sometimes
listening to them really helps me out
yeah um they're they're good at doing
the the important bits but also always
keeping that flare of fun and improv the
life it seems so smart I would like love
to meet them like I would genuinely and
I've had some a minor exchange with uh
James on Twitter very minor like it's
public you can read it but we both
geeked out you showed me that and I was
like oh my God like there there are a
couple of people in this sphere who I
would still be like Star Struck to me
yeah yeah I'd be nervous to talk yeah
absolutely like I'm so so functions
[Laughter]
really I'd be insecure like a wonderful
audition man yeah please like me I'm not
cool enough so I'm not embarrassed by
you I need to live up to you somehow
um Lethal Weapon is one of koi's
favorite movies I've never seen any
Lethal Weapon maybe one day the crow
with Bill Skarsgard uh I I am so back
and forth on whether or not I'm actually
excited for this or not it doesn't
matter it's not gonna happen it's never
gonna happen I keep imagining a trailer
for The Crow with Bill Skarsgard and
it's like super I keep imagining how
they pitched like the Daredevil Ben
Affleck
I don't know how hard I've seen like a
really good version of this you need
some of that uh a Counter Culture 90s
Camp to go with it you need a little bit
of that I've read the crow graphic novel
and it is different from the from the
movie the movie I think does a really
good adaptation actually it is it is an
adaptation it's not like extremely
accurate but I think if they do lean a
little bit more kind of like how Batman
leaned more into the emo side I think
you do that here sure
um with the with the rock side of him uh
but yeah the the comic book is different
from the from the movie the movie they
made it a movie yeah but I like the
movie a lot I love the movie well and I
think too now like especially with the
way emo and pop punk are so like back in
galvanized in the music scene you know
it would be a good way to update the you
know rock and roll palettes too like
it's a good timing for it but something
about that movie I just feel like is is
still not going to happen even though
Bill Skarsgard is like one of the better
choices they've come up with but Michael
robell thank you Michael the best movie
and show that I really enjoyed this year
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness and
stranger things 4. to be honest in my
opinion yeah you stick to that Honesty
there's not many people are going to
declare Doctor Strange as their number
one nope
but uh squid game this year not this
year yeah okay good yeah I was gonna say
that's not first kill not familiar with
that oh
bullet train seems I think bullet train
because it wasn't a hit has surprised
people are like this is actually really
enjoyable film I think it appreciates
value on home video yeah yeah
yeah I was good with watching you know
yeah yeah I'm like I could see what
would be fun about this in theaters but
I also feel like this is the right size
for this to actually play pretty well
everyone is happy that fast and furious
10 is going to movie theaters doing yeah
everyone is happy right I
really wish Dwayne Johnson could figure
something out there I still am I'm in
the camp I'm gonna die on this hill I
think they've worked it out and they're
just K fabing they're wrestling it I
don't know like as much as it does seem
like no they have a real Feud I think
they're I think they're K fabing there's
got to be a way for him to come back for
the end I just feel like once it becomes
real it'll happen but maybe I'm not as
confident about that as the crow not
coming
Tyler Tyler thank you are you guys
excited for the Tarantino series I think
it's being filmed in 2023 Yeah by
default I am excited I think Tarantino
is really prolonging his last film yeah
I'm gonna make my first mini series now
I'm gonna make a couple of books uh
maybe a place series now I'm gonna start
a podcast I'm gonna make an ongoing
series I'm gonna make a web series I'm
gonna keep myself super busy yeah until
this last film coming yeah and then when
he's 95 years old he finally announces
what the last film will be and then
he'll die making it well I I mean he
he's someone who adapts and I think that
with television especially with what
it's become it's perfect for a guy like
Tarantino Ramble On for 10 episodes I
know yeah
I really I really love the idea of
Tarantino doing a series and the fact
that he's had stuff like hateful eight
have an Extended Cut with the four of
the divide into four episodes uh
Tarantino just doing a series and
someone who consumes content like he's
he consumes shows and movies I I don't
know how a guy who creates as well as he
does is able to just consume books
Comics oh maybe not Comics as much but
books yeah and movies and shows and
raise a family and make a movie I don't
know how he does that all uh is he
raising a family you just get married no
he's kidding everything about his kid
constantly completely missed tell
stories about his kid all the time I
missed a child Tino damn all right he's
he's a full-grown man no no it's okay
but you can still go it's heavy spoilers
in the chat he is in the chat wow Greg
looks like the cool guy I mean a lot of
Chipotle you you are the cool guy get
that sofritas
[Laughter]
come on now
um I really want I'm really excited for
Chris stuckman to have his movie come
out yeah Shelby Oaks I would fly to Ohio
to watch it be screened there oh go back
give me the goddamn Ohio yes you can
stand my in my grandparents old house
um Blue Beetle Aquaman flash Shazam 2
will probably have Fox's dark Phoenix
System since the universe is getting
rebooted yeah still looking forward to
Blue Beetle
I don't I mean it might keep Blue Beetle
because too if there's not too much
overlap with a film like Blue Beetle
then yeah you could just keep that
Steve Harrington did you know that he
has a pain yeah Joe I just started
listening to his music this year listen
Olivia played a song for me in the car
right back I don't know what but then it
was almost like oh did you know this is
uh Joe Curry I was like what yeah you
hear the album and you're like oh snap
really and it is like uh it is like a uh
uh it's a little eccentric it is like an
80s rock band which I'm funny enough but
I'm like good good on him yeah it
actually works better yeah oh now I'm
curious because he was in a band and now
he's been doing like solo albums oh
that's how I've come to know his I have
no idea musical output the best is
people going man this the stuff he
releases is just Joe DJ I mean he's got
a Swagger about him that reads like a
dude who performs on stage sure yeah
um yeah I like his music yo you guys
you're awesome Tangled over Marvel
Tangled was good I like Tangled we we
will saw that for the first time this
year I do miss the Spider-Man no way
homie around I know that was the time
that was a very alive time
uh njs thank you so much we'd love to
hear your thoughts on treason if you
have watched it I definitely liked it
however I'm not sure if I absolutely
loved it is that that's the Charlie Cox
Show
I think I think I saw I think it popped
up as a recommended for me it is
I pay attention to it I'm always curious
to see how how my algorithm is reading
on any platform I'm at I'm like what's
being recommended to me I'm always
curious and I believe that was
recommended to me all right I'm not
familiar with it but it did it did
strike me
um weirdly enough
and I felt bad having this feeling
I'm like oh this is the problem when
you're cornered and now I'm having now
I'm having a bit of a divide oh when
you're Typecast or or you're stuck in
the bottle of a roll sure it was Charlie
Cox as treason
and and I went
yeah not playing a blind guy
but Matt Murphy I don't wanna
watch this because he's not Daredevil I
found myself not interested about myself
having that feeling of oh I I don't want
to watch him not be Daredevil for some
reason and I went that's not good I need
to I need to give him a shot because I'm
not familiar with if I I'm not like have
I even seen Charlie like Daredevil is my
favorite you know and I went have I even
seen him
play someone not Daredevil yet
okay I I don't know if I have I haven't
seen Stardust I have seen oh goodness
I've seen bits of Stardust and I know I
saw him in it but I don't really have
like a good recollection the one thing I
remember definitely seeing his
performance in was uh the Stephen
Hawking movie
he's uh with uh with Eddie redmastic
Beast yeah yeah he's in he's a
supporting character I believe in that
movie and he was good he's good he's
Charming very much not a matte Murdoch
type character so it was nice to see him
at least get that range in also we've
kind of to the point of the chat where
we were talking about Andrew Tate
and now uh people are debating the
legitimacy of the pizza story oh did it
was it real or are we about to get red
pilled right now let's see
I did want to shout really quick because
I don't think this is going to come up
as like an actual question but I did
want to uh shout out um there was one
movie I saw this year that was like a
completely independent movie that a
friend of mine Becca Becca you know you
know Becca from back in the day
um she invited me to see this movie that
her friend made and it was called big
fun and I went and it was one of those
things where you're going to like a
friend of a friend's movie you don't
know what you're expecting there were
technical difficulties and the movie
started late and the movie turned out to
be big fun like it was really quirky and
funny but also kind of touching and it
was one of those movie experiences it
was uh it's by a guy called John walk up
and uh Bree claproth uh they co-wrote it
together and uh and yeah it was a quirky
Charming comedy that kept me sort of
I don't know it's like inspiring it was
like cool these are like real people I
can tangibly identify making a movie
that is actually playing really well to
this house of people who have been
waiting and are also here out of the
graciousness of being friends and so
yeah it was like a cool completely
anti-like you know not attached to
anything Hollywood or anything that
we're doing in here but it was like oh
cool like I'm inspired to you know just
get some friends together and make
something and that's a a nice valuable
feeling so getting like the inspiration
off of movies like top gun Maverick or
Avatar 2 was great and then to go to
something that is like as independent as
you could get I thought was a really
lovely experience and I've thought back
on it a few times since that happened a
couple months back so look out for big
fun if uh you know if you're looking
around wherever it happens to drop
uh but they're on social media and it
was a cool movie experience of 2022 that
I put on my top 10 list because it meant
something to me
that's amazing to hear John thank you
for attending my TED talk I will gladly
watch big fun one day yeah it's funny it
was a good fun quirky character comedy
how do I change the dimensions uh just
click it and then mess with the box and
uh oh you broke it
okay there you go and then uh do you
hold on let me check you're going behind
the box too much
oh hey look we can crunch the Box even
yeah to make it wider I mean taller
taller
give me a little weird and unpleasant to
the eye
we are not going to adjust the actual
magnification again but
yeah here let's Let's uh if we each move
a little bit to the other side
there you go that's not too bad right no
man is that too bad nice
should end soon we should have got to go
to some families
it's it's Nye we got lives yeah we've
got nyu's things to do and then many
other people too uh we did talk about a
house with the dragon Hot D Aldi all D
every D I think I think he's gonna have
a season to a peacemaker he's got to I
imagine he'll I imagine James Gunn will
uh Peacemaker is lucky because aside
from that Justice League appearance
there's not too much that really tethers
you to the current but do you know that
that is the next wave of the
conversations whoever gets saved will
then experience the backlash for
yeah it will be that Emilio maliro thank
you if you were to reimagine any IPA
reboot any movie for 2023 what you do
fear to reimagine any IP or reboot for
any movie for 2023
damn that's a hard question just to have
off the Dome yeah reboot anyway has
there been any movie Willy Wonka
Halloween ends yes rebooting I wanted to
do it redo Game of Thrones season eight
redo it
redoed all of the Snyder verse
um hey yeah let's reboot DC in 2020. I
think that's the same message
um damn that's a great question I'll
keep thinking I'll have to think a
little bit more on that yeah
I wonder what the first fear of the real
rejects will be in 2023. odds are
Wednesday episode two yeah yep yep that
looks that's looking likely already
almost ready to go hey we're back to the
Chipotle comment someone is copying
comments oh stopped oh so me and Philip
were talking about that show that cat as
well heavy spoilers my friend he's a
great guy I'm very very very thankful
for for Paul he's an amazing gentleman
he's really
uh undoubtedly uh become one of my
absolute closest friends and he is still
uh
he's very much within the community
YouTubers like so I don't know we talked
to like way more than me and uh he's
he's uh if it would be a complete and
utterly to say he has not been
undoubtedly extremely helpful to the to
the channel you guys have no clue how
helpful he's been
and also on the topic of shouting out
other YouTuber friends Warren Cosmic
Wonder of course
um Philip Molina and other great guy
who's really been helpful Ryan Airy uh
some amazing met some amazing friends in
this field
uh we have definitely like anybody fan
fictasia train here oh yeah the next
next
friends with Mr Sunday
yeah oh my God and I'm like I could do
that and I'll be like I don't even be
friends with anyone else you know what I
want I want to reboot the Dark Universe
yeah that'd be good yeah it's a way to
do that do an actual good Dark Universe
that'd be nice or reboot the mummies
with Brendan Fraser but that would be
just more sequels so yeah reboot the
Dark Universe I think that would be cool
okay no no shade to Lee 1 L's Invisible
Man and Ryan Gosling qualities you wanna
honor that's awesome I like honoring
things you guys need to watch Barry I
have seen Barry I need to fill in the
gaps I saw one episode this year and it
was the one with the barista
unless it's a reoccurring character
people keep going into the shop and
there's this white guy yeah yeah
people sure are demanding in here you
picked your last thing
anytime we put out something we're like
react to this uh you guys make my day so
much better thank you for all you do
thank you Isaiah obey your Buster us
thank you Disney fan that's a really
nice compliment
Jane in the Autobots Irishman watch
along with Greg and Coy moderator John
Wayne I wanted John Holden koi and I'm
back that is the new format is we'll do
a react Series where where we put you
two on either side of the screen and
then me up top at the middle as the
judge and then you guys react to a part
until you come under a conflict and yeah
and then we duke it out and then we
continue the movie it would be really
hard at it
but there's something in there I feel
like when Corey and I disagree in a
movie it's mainly because the themes
speak massive volumes to him
whereas they they don't and I'm more
focused on like yeah but the actual
execution of the Journey's not really
clicking for me I feel like yeah yeah I
think that's a fair note because it's
like I can sometimes when we're when
I've witnessed the argument I'm like I
can see the theme that you are pointing
out it is a good theme but the
articulation of the theme in the script
isn't actually as rich as just you
running away and yeah you know
extrapolating on it
um Wendy Happy New Year to you Wendy and
Dustin yeah I say when you Dustin but I
know just when we only care about what
we highly doubt it's Dustin there I know
that's Dustin yeah all right Dustin's
always plugged in man he's always on I
know what's up there he's always on it's
like when I'm commenting on other
people's live streams people are like
just Greg or John I'm like trust me it's
me I'm the one it's typically you but
sometimes you never know yeah I think
it's more likely to be me than Dustin
but it's usually going to be you or
Wendy it's almost always going to be
yours John's super chatting people
through like using my credit card
I did jump into a stream once I had the
inclination that I wait I I remembered
oh wait time not on my account
I will not I will change accounts
oh yeah but I want that Irishman rage
watch I want it
one maybe we might react to Fan Fantasia
episode three I know we we just did not
commitment I totally missed it with two
came out and three honestly I was like
we're on three already damn that's right
these exist
um it's been a while Danny H thank you
for the moment of silence oh Kevin
Shepherd Gremlins too huh I haven't seen
Gremlins do I haven't seen Gremlins or
Gremlins too oh Grandma's that would be
good yeah we gotta started going into
the corners until the big one comes out
yes so we gotta and now that like it's
still kind of christmas-esque time we
gotta ring those last holiday movies out
like Christmas oh my God it's like a
horror movie yeah but don't people pull
it out at Christmas time is it like a
semi Christmas I would never be like
Christmas time guys
yeah okay that's fair I I guess there's
like a Christmas backdrop to it but it's
nice okay I want to call it if you're a
if you're a horror movie nerd you're
more looking more than it is
you can squint and go die hard Christmas
Gremlins Christmas yeah I haven't seen
Gremlins too I imagine that'd be fun
actually in the past couple years I've
actually heard better Arguments for why
Die Hard is a Christmas movie and it's
not about Christmas [ __ ] it's more about
like it's about this guy trying to put
his family together and try to get back
to them and protect them for the
holidays so they can like all spend
Christmas together and it's like oh
that's a good point
um Bruce Willis has declared that it's
not a Christmas movie oh well I changed
my mind then he said it on his roast of
Bruce Willis he said I did this so I can
tell everyone once and for all
Die Hard is not a Christmas movie you
know what the inventor of gifts still
says they're called gifs and uh tomato
tomato what an idiot
uh black end of that bit Eddie must
return that's the that is the most
conflicting feeling I have toward 2023
right now is if they are four whenever
this stranger things 5 comes out is I
will be very happy to see Eddie Muntz in
return I have no idea how that could
happen in a way that doesn't feel like
ah [ __ ] we shouldn't have killed him I'm
very much
um I am a contribution to the problem of
return characters really In This Moment
In Tiding into Netflix In This Moment In
Time
the thought of Robert Downey Jr
returning to Iron Man has been going
around everywhere
does not excite me not yet I don't like
it
I know me well enough to know this when
it happened when the announcement
happens
what do you mean then
surprises in the theaters oh my God holy
[ __ ] he's back here I did oh my God I
cry I know me well enough to know that's
that's what my brain operates so I'm
like ah you know we'll screw it he's
here we might as well enjoy it yeah yeah
waiting longer would be my inclination
but yeah when it happens it'll be a rush
of joy and excitement I do I I the one
thing when I reflect on what Multiverse
of Madness it I do think like knowing
Patrick Stewart's last Xavier
performance
was that treatment for multiversa
madness as a meme is is like oh man they
really done him dirty and this would be
like it doesn't really make much of an
impression he got murked like a [ __ ] he
looks a little silly in that chair and
then he just gets taken out you know and
uh and it's like Patrick Stewart man you
got to give him like some real scenes
here like that that is some as much as I
defend that movie I I also I'm like out
of anyone in the Illuminati him that
should have done more service that's
yeah there should have been a lasting
impactful beat or moment or something
significant that he does and you know
what I noticed in that Illuminati fight
of what really undercuts the tension
as I actually rewatched the fight uh I
think like two days ago just randomly
put it on okay and it's the fact this is
their problem when they keep secrets
from all the [ __ ] actors and I'm like
don't worry you're not supposed to know
that no one feels like they're in the
same room yeah is when they die
they're not reacting emotionally at all
to any of them die yeah there's no
response yeah totally oh that's a great
and that undercuts so much like there's
not even like a cliche no black ball I
don't know yeah it is just like they're
just dead yep gotta keep dealing with
this I guess yeah it is and that's that
was a throwaway that was one of the
longest but I still love the scene but
it would have made it that much fun it's
weird and so much of that movie has that
quality where you're like I really like
what this is but this doesn't feel like
the definitive version of what this
could have been and there's something
that stuck with me one of the most Sage
pieces of advice I ever heard in film
school is one of the most simple too is
like get reaction shots and get
reactions from characters and you're in
the writing of this because reactions
sell so much and they are easy to
overlook that and and get yourself some
extras it'll make everything look better
um sometimes reaction to something
before you actually see what it is
reacting to also worked sure Kevin Mando
plot twist Tarantino's final movie will
be a superhero flick I would love to see
him do it it'll be his Luke Cage movie
I've always thought it would be great
for him to go out with his first sequel
uh Kill Bill 3.
like he would do a trifecta it would be
a Trilogy and it would be his first
sequel it would be like that weird thing
yeah yeah yeah you know the unintended
Trilogy his first real part two
and and it would be a Trilogy and it
would show like he hasn't done that he
hasn't done us a follow-up film oh and
there's and there and then that could
play on an era of Cinemas yeah like the
Aged Warrior the older Samurai whatever
it is I think if we knock it out of the
park yeah and that would and that would
lend itself to the passage of time more
so than I think something like the Vega
brothers or something because obviously
oh man just de-age them that will go
well
get him and James Cameron to work
together X is one film I am and I want
to do it earlier this year he's gonna
get around to it
oh hey guys thank you Ismail Ismail just
on National Treasure edge of history and
the first two episodes were alone
started getting really good do you guys
like National Treasure never seen any
National Treasure but I am a treasure
protector I haven't seen any National
Treasure oh man I think I've seen more
movies than you you probably have seen
it before but I've well perhaps but I've
also probably seen more like obscure
random old movies and stuff oh
undoubtedly yeah you've seen more of the
moderns
I don't know at the time I wasn't like
gotta check this out
I didn't see the sequel
you didn't see that book of
Shadows uh I I don't I don't remember
the plot of National Treasure I can't I
I can tell you something about the Mona
Lisa technology yeah
I don't know it was all right I I don't
I don't have of I'll react super fond
memory of it but I remember being amused
I'll react to the first movie
buddy wait so do you guys watch the HBO
show Titans Teen Titans I don't watch
Titans I'm on the third season of Doom
Patrol unfortunately uh I'm not I mean
fortunately I'm unfortunately I'm
unfortunately watching this I haven't
started Titans no no
um Oliver Hamlin
John looks like the type of guy who will
let you take that last part of working
spot at the point in that guy he's that
guy I am that guy if there was any
question that it wasn't maybe mine uh
yeah sure I would do it if I didn't I
would I I would take the spot if I
didn't make eye contact
if I could play it off legitimately like
I didn't do this either yeah
yeah I would get caught in a moral
dilemma and I would debate it with
myself in the split seconds before
pulling in and then I would go yeah okay
oh my God airpods
have helped get me out of so many
grocery store encounters sure of walking
into stores and leaving them and just
like just go with people always asking
me for [ __ ] pretend to be on a call then
I end up doing it anyway or I'm just
like ah [ __ ] I hurt them uh I don't it's
hard to do this it's like it's hard to
stand outside I don't really know what
this is but there's so many people like
their kids out here with and and I and I
was so compelled like I gotta give you
money man uh is is the kids basketball
team the basketball team ones that's
what it is and and I'm not I just I'm
not familiar with the concept of it of
like they what are they doing raising
money to do what for basketball yeah
it's either I always imagine just either
for travel to play other teams or for
gear and stuff if I see a kid out there
I'm just like it's [ __ ] like 10
o'clock at night and he's in high school
and you feel the weird crushing weight
of the overarching system where you're
like okay so you're like out here on
your own appealing to people's goodness
to try and fund your thing and you're
also selling like basic candy bars for
way above what they're worth it's like
you know you get like a five dollar
chocolate bar half the time I don't even
take it honestly I'm just like here yeah
or the coupons they give them like I'm
not gonna use these coupons just take
yeah just here's some cash I don't eat
meat so I'm not going to
Wienerschnitzels
they have to have a Beyond weiner by now
who's the better fighter Robbie mceller
Hawk uh Robbie is definitely the better
fight like in terms of performer Robbie
I don't know about character I think
Hawk may be the the fighteriest fighter
but but yeah Robbie Sells that chisel
damn favorite Cobra Kai scene and again
it's hard to pinpoint a [ __ ] scene
that's like
I I really love the three finale
when they uh
what what the convergence at the dojo
when uh Johnny and Daniel team up yeah
that was by Chris that was a great fight
that was the the the most yeah like that
I gotta be so hyped for the break and
subsequencies and yeah
that was yeah that was that was a plus
terrific not sure about this yet I'm
gonna decide to do it before honestly
it's about bad batch Danny H happy New
Year guys loved your Schindler's List
reaction another movie Set during the
Holocaust so I recommend is The Pianist
Adrian Brody is amazing in it oh yeah
um
I know he would get canceled for some
[ __ ] like that today but no
should I still love Adrian Brody good
question for the day
I'm always happy to see Adrian Brody uh
Predators is underrated I would like to
find more fun movies right now uh but
perhaps yeah I should add that to a list
um it's gonna be so fun
anyone involved in the making of off of
or signing off on shio should be fired
immediately
I think a terrible show was bad enough
they'd reduced Daredevil to a ridiculous
clown
other than this but I don't agree I
don't agree with this take uh the
biggest fan 94 thank you for the moment
of silence Oh Happy New Year's Eve to
you Pam impossible
what happened
don't worry John it's back on don't
worry you didn't pull it John we will be
ending the stream of relatively soon
relatively
G fuel keep it as fuel throughout the
whole stream hey I love this Mega Man
one shouts out to the band Proto men who
just did a new song and they sing cool
ass rock opera jams about Mega Man I am
not completely alleviated on the worry
of Disney plus Daredevil ship not after
Charlie Cox came out and said some vague
thing about maybe he's a variant but
kind of not not after the I don't know
if it'll be as violent I don't think it
needs to be as it does feel like the
violence though was a staple
it's like of course you can do it
whether it doesn't need to be gory like
of course you can but it needs to feel
violent it needs to feel like a violent
world and I think Daredevil one of its
trademarks was this [ __ ] is bloody this
is Gory well yeah you're in Hell's
Kitchen you're with a character called
Daredevil like there should be a
harshness to this world yeah there is
something that I especially when you're
bringing over Charlie Cox and Vincent
D'Onofrio who smashed the guy's goddamn
head in um in a car I I think and then
got real nerfed when they brought him
into the MCU I I I do feel like you need
that's something that I ca I have a hard
time meeting fans on like I don't know I
could I could adjust and be like all
right another really PG dude
but I I can I I do feel like
it is hard for me to get them booed
without it being violent
it doesn't work around because it is
such a unfortunately there are all the
comics were and everything I'm like I
don't know man freaking Karen Page was
like a goddamn heroin addict and
Daredevil Born Again sure I think you
can yeah I think you can uh I think you
have to go really
you got to go in the heavy you gotta
have the grit you gotta have grit for
that it's like if you were honestly like
if you were starting over a new
Daredevil like not Charlie Cox not
Vincent d'onofrio's Kingpin fine then
you could do your thing where it's not
as bloody and stuff but if you are
bringing them over I kind of feel like
it's necessary well you just have no
choice but to be reminded if you've seen
any of the previous shows of the
previous shows like doing a blade movie
gotta be bloody as hell it sounds weird
to me like it sounds odd
it is but they're not doing a Wesley so
maybe they can make it work in a
different lens you know yeah I mean and
and I I do appreciate people coming out
and basically I think even koi was was
the main one I saw say that yeah it's
like Daredevil the comics aren't only
one voice and even in She-Hulk to go
back to that last comment like I don't
think he totally got made into a clown
like I was like okay he gives me much
more hope than seeing Vincent D'Onofrio
in uh Hawkeye did but at the same time
the combination of the length of the
show with these concerns has yeah I will
be nervous until it comes out I think I
think the thing with Daredevil being
rated
the ra I'm not saying like they need to
push Gore like a lot of the best moments
of Daredevil like the hallway fight's
not gory the hallway fight's just a
really well shot and choreographed fight
scene it's when a moment that
should be violent or bloody is obviously
really watered down that's when it's
gonna really underplay the show [ __ ]
morbius when that guy got his throat
slapped yeah and just nothing came out
yeah someone gets shot and there's no
like blood or something like like if if
they movies and shows are better than
than Everett at making things feel
violent without showing you blood like
there are fights in like season one when
Daredevils like getting [ __ ] up with
the uh the guy from The Hand they keep
coming back forth this fight I'm like
that is a brutal bloody fight and so
painful you feel the pain or or the
final fight with Kingpin in him you know
um that's a sort of brutal so
they even introduced Punisher and
Daredevil which is into it that was a
violent [ __ ] yeah and I'm like how is
that character you know the Punisher
will come back there's talk of maybe
even having John Bernthal come back like
that's what I mean it's like if that
character persists if I think if you
want to set the stage for punisher to be
super violent you you ought to keep
Daredevil violent so that way you can
help introduce thought real violence
keep Daredevil violence if you introduce
the violence with dared up like oh this
is definitely the R-rated side of Marvel
Now
I like the [ __ ] what's bizarre to me
is like why not keep it violent when
they put all the Netflix shows on Disney
plus yeah and they're not water they're
the exact same show yes so there's
what's the point like there's no point
in doing it you've already put that
there yeah I mean yeah it's like the
ideal scenario is keep the violence keep
the blood but I think if they can strike
the balance of like okay this is still
violent if not bloody gory that could it
could still work but yeah I think it's
just gonna be trepidation until
the episodes are in and we know hey just
wanted to say from cam I'm an autistic
adult and I just remember my true
passion is oh that's awesome in here
buddy uh theater and film not just any
one fandom there's a reason I was drawn
instinctively towards your channel oh
thank you Cam so much thank you thank
you Trooper buddy thank you I got a big
love for theater as well I have played
high on life oh is it good yeah this is
all good for them I've heard so many
sort of like backlashy takes but yeah
was your opinion on the female race
wouldn't be here without them
uh hate them don't need him cam spirited
with Ryan Reynolds with Will Ferrell was
the exact story I needed here this year
I do want to watch that I do I I want to
watch that too
the writers of die of the film and says
diet is a Christmas movie I love Bruce
Willis but he's wrong
it's a gift damn it I feel like the
forever debate lingers on it will never
die there will never be a good it's all
an eye to be the holder G
um yeah and Gremlins is too it's
confirmed in the chat Brianna J
confirmed all right it's fine so you're
wrong forever and and I win life
uh Marvel this year was mid DC was fired
with Batman but movie of the year is Top
Gun love you guys man I would be yeah oh
by the way I am planning on reacting to
Matilda Alfie
um the original movie
yeah why is there something else
there's a new musical I think oh show
thing yeah just an original movie yeah
shouts out tomorrow the Batman I'd be so
bummed if James Gunn removes that
because we haven't gotten anything like
the Batman like we've got a bunch of
Batman but we haven't got it we haven't
gotten a Batman interpretation like that
I was thinking that's what I was
thinking about in the car right back
like man that is the most film Noir
version of Batman totally and and it's
the best position I would be so bummed
if that did not carry on where you get
to watch him learn the importance of
making uh a family out of him uh
learning the idea of dual identity and
stuff dual identity and True Justice
versus like you know if vengeance is the
theme in the first movie True Justice
has to be a theme in the next movie
yeah uh it is a stupid idea to bring RDJ
back
yeah the idea that people are theorizing
that's a it's a different Universe Tony
Stark
I don't know man as different Universe
Charles Xavier but I feel like it was
the professor Patrick Stewart I think is
his impact of return would just be
greatly heightened by more time away
like I get that I guess you still want
him not to look like an old man or
something but yeah I don't know I feel
like the longer you wait the better but
you know we'll see which flavors of
g-filled do I like I like their Sonic
the Hedgehog Peach flavor I like the uh
click bait one a lot
um the morbius plasma flavors the best
one this really work
um hello to Sri Lanka
no I don't because don't subscribe to
that thought process cam no the only way
to I gotta watch [ __ ] severance I
know it is one of the most like
consistently mentioned shows in the last
couple years for for my azim the dream
reviews hey guy thank you for the Super
Chat how'd you all rank Jurassic
franchise oh that's easy one one and
then a big old bunch of empty slots
and then two threes
uh uh Fallen Kingdom
Dominion world can fight for the bottom
spot wow that's wild to me we have
different rankings uh Jurassic Park
Jurassic world oh uh Jurassic uh part
two the Lost World
Jurassic Park
three actually I might knock three down
one of the world ones above the world
Dominion
yeah no no no no I would say drastic
minion I don't know they can fight there
that's really fine either way two
Jurassic worlds are fighting at the
bottom Tyler uh
oh damn that's a great idea what Kill
Bill 3 with Maya hawk playing her
daughter grown-up could work well and
then get Ethan Hawkins Ethan Hawk to
play yes
the ghost of Bill that haunts Maya
totally I'm haunted by my dad bill
oh no it's your baby
oh
you know that would be so cool what a
great way to see them paired up that
would be cool AF yeah yeah
vernita Green's daughter then you could
do that whole thing too there you go
yeah she's coming with the Creed
franchise
kill Creed it's just a kid's fighting it
out now yeah man that's the perfect way
to do Legacy sequels
it's so candy bars in high school to buy
our own uniforms okay yeah it is
sold my body for clothes
what do you think Ghost Riders returning
to the MCU and who you want to play him
necklace cage
okay people want Keanu to do it would
you be actually excited if it happened
yes absolutely I think it'd be great I'm
Joni please you know what people are
always fighting for
um representation and [ __ ]
and I gotta say
I don't ever hear people you know I'm
I'm Filipino
you never hear me [ __ ] about not having
any Filipinos and [ __ ]
you should start and I'm gonna start
doing that I want a Filipino guy to play
Ghost you need one good angry thread to
you know extrapolate throughout the [ __ ]
Malcolm there's no Filipinos in anything
they're always playing Filipino yeah
yeah Dante Bosco has that movie about
his life on Hulu or whatever because
there's some actors who are like half
Filipino I don't know if there's any are
there any popular type of Filipino
actors
Rob Schneider was one yeah yeah yeah oh
it's with an f and an F that's how not
John just typed in Filipino actors with
a pH I know Pinoy hates and you know
what that's why we need more Filipino
actors out there goddamn to enlightened
white folks like I uh Diamond Phillips
all right cool cool that's the biggest
one always playing Latinos I know that's
well that's the problem you gotta get
some real
filipino-centric content okay yeah I
think that's the next that's what we
gotta start with it's like a a very
strong Filipino character and then we go
now let's have them just play people
without them doing Filipino people yeah
he's gonna transcend the genre of only
doing your own culture we need some
Filipino actors out here God damn it
yeah yeah there aren't a lot of like
super Wellness I'm all for Joe coyce
hilarious
but God damn it we need some Filipinos
out there Dante Bosco and Lou Diamond
Phillips cannot be holding down the
whole fort
Dan do we not really happen those are
Filipino actresses okay I feel like
there's an actress out there who's
Filipino who I'm just not thinking of
see if you can because this kind of
bummed me out
says
um man
I don't know maybe someone of the chats
got me here yeah it'll come for a while
I thought Rock might have had something
that's not Filipino that's not Filipino
at all it's the Hawaiian
Pacific Islander
that's what I'm talking about yeah man
we got to finally see his whole it's
okay it's it's funny it took until Hobbs
and Shaw to have like a whole you know
samoan-centric Rock movie that's what
I'm talking about let's watch Young Rock
in 2023 I've heard it's okay
morbtastic cage and I agree every every
morbtastic day above ground is a gift
let's not forget John fravo did do elf
it is the last modern Christmas classic
I think like I can't think of a movie
that has achieved that status for
Christmas movies in recent memory that
isn't elf I do want to watch this Grinch
horror movie I am excited for it it's
got art the clown in it see I get what
everyone's saying I I knew these
comments like this would come in I'm
saying that it's of course maturity and
darkness can be portrayed maturity
Darkness themes can be portrayed
um in Daredevil without it having to be
gory I'm not saying it needs to be a
Gore Fest I was specifically citing that
what a moment
warrants a gory moment it'll be
distracting yeah because you have
Charlie Cox and Vincent D'Onofrio back
in there and it's clear that they are
trying the Lightroom
it's clear that they are trying to uh
yeah Salvage the Goodwill of what came
before but also in this weird rut of
like but we can't
quite for self-imposed reasons I don't
know it's weird it's a weird one to
think about it was so exciting the
announcement and now I have so many more
like Rising trepidations I think and we
don't have confirmation if like Karen
pay if uh no not yet Deborah Ann wollen
and them are coming back either right I
think Marvel still had a better year and
I agree with this that sentiment Marvel
wasn't bad this year but it was at its
weekend I don't I think it was not its
strongest year it's the most phase one
it's felt since phase one very for for
but even phase one was still exciting
because it was like we're gonna get
those Avengers never mind the most phase
two it's Felton
phase two head Captain America
it's probably the most it's probably the
most akin to that yeah
um
Connie's saying Connie got me a butt
plug candle everything everywhere all at
once was of course my favorite I had so
much fun watching the Batman with you
guys and I was happy to have you there
all excited to see some more flicks with
you in 2023. you're so funny we can sit
together and pretend not to cry love you
Connie you gotta hang out soon love you
for stopping by friend yeah Jurassic
more getting hungry my my stomach is
churning oh I haven't eaten yet today
what's Haley Steinfeld does not have
Filipina really yes she is that's the
ACT that's literally the actress that
I'm saying she is part Filipino I type
her in on a Wikipedia
oh my God that's the thing but no
there's not like you know like Filipino
characters that I mean I'm sure there
are and like something but I mean like a
big a big thing you know
big big thing big big thing yeah yeah
yeah there needs to be yeah some kind of
big breakout starring role that doesn't
even clue you into them being Filipino
but you know it's like oh cool is
Filipino it's like a weird hodgepodge of
because it's like there's a Asian
Pacific Islander I'm like I think we're
both that's yeah yeah
hey so Haley Steinfeld is like uh is uh
you know like uh Anya Taylor Joy is like
half Arjun Argentine or something like
that and you're like oh damn like you
know you you pass as white she has
acknowledged that but also like oh damn
I wouldn't have known like so that's
cool
so you got to be out here always more
bad she's got to be one of those Haley
Steinfeld should become one of those
people who you know has like a little
bit of certain thing in the mix that
their whole identity I would be okay
like like I I I'd be totally fine if she
you know play like a character who's
full Filipino sure
I'm like all right cool that's a good
step
yeah and then watch her get this a
backlash for whitewashing oh it's Dave
Bautista Dave Bautista looks like he
could be Filipinos tap that in
but no one's leading with their Filipino
Filipino grandfather got Filipino
grandfathers so he's got a bit of uh a
bit of a Philippine he's got Filipino
descent in it half Filipino which is the
Philippines flag tattoo Filipino side
flag tattooed on your chest Batista
where is your pride
it's like that weird thing now where you
do I get I get it now as someone who's
like yeah I feel like there's like no
real Filipino representation in movies
yeah where it's like but I I love it
more when you when you're not only
playing that or you're just when you
just play people yeah when it's not what
like I love that level of diversity when
you're just playing people and you're
not talking about their race there is
that thing though where I'm like
sometimes I feel like it does warrant it
though where you to have a little bit of
a push I'm telling you man the Dante
Bosco movie he's got a whole family in
it and it's like we're growing up Philip
or you know so it's our lives is
Filipinos a bit of a film just a
Filipino cultural touch would be nice
you know as that can be the mark you
bring to Hollywood like they put all the
Latino people underworld at the bottom
of the sea that's right black panther
you guys stay down yeah we ain't got no
land left for you yeah you don't come up
here shitty ass soaking water
go live where no one else can live white
and black people up here yeah we don't
need you in between us and then the
Asian people have their own little
mysterious land over here yeah
you gotta you gotta Zen out as you drive
through the bamboo forest
laughs
it's a very interestingly segregated
Universe in the Marvel World
Germans
Jermaine Jake's uh I want the good news
and the bad news broken up so where it's
one one word of good one word of bad and
and kind of displaced them that way and
we'll decipher accordingly
um Joshua Jenkins all this me me thank
you Joe Coy is hilarious he's John
campius favorite person alive I know he
loves him he loves kind of Filipino
fetish that can't be him he does might
be doing something we can't be it by the
way um
tune in as I make comments like that
which will get me to not do things with
campuses is it some kind of Canada
versus Philippines yeah based show
scatter brain uh no Ann's great by the
way they're my parents scatter brain
reviews you think Oppenheimer will feel
like older style Nolan from the Memento
days insomnia love tenet but hype for a
more personal film scope happy New Years
much love I wonder how much Nolan
actually takes in
um by criticism and reviews like does he
actually
I feel like to a certain extent a lot of
filmmakers it's hard for me to believe
every filmmaker who's like I don't read
any of it I feel like he has to because
tenet especially had that response
and
um
tenant feels like it should have been
way more of like a big thing than what
it ultimately wound up to be well it was
the pandemic movie sure yeah I drove an
hour and a half to go watch
you know can't be able to do the whole
thing where he drove to Vegas to watch
it you know like I I drove a while to to
go see it in the theaters and
it did it was like man there's like no
character
it's all action explanation of [ __ ] and
and I'm sorry Nolan but if your film is
all about all that you gotta have better
audio I don't care what you're saying
about but it doesn't matter I'm like it
totally matters it compounding your
whole movie yeah all right it's all yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah if we can't hear
them and the dialogue's not important
then
yeah like and I was hearing up on
Inception that that whole thing with his
daughter and everything like that was a
it might have been suggestion from
DiCaprio to have something like that so
there was a more I could be wrong I know
it was a suggestion from someone else
that wasn't part of his original script
interesting that is good good and then
someone said we need that for an
emotional pull for inception for him to
have like a a daughter he's fighting to
get back to and have a core yeah and and
it drastically helps the film out it
does not like you meet this kid and
you're [ __ ] hanging out with them or
anything yeah but it really helps you
get in your Dobbs uh and I I I think
that it was the desperate need of that
it really is at Dunkirk even that was
like warrants because there's some
Dunkirk has more of an emotional thing
that you can latch onto it has the
communal emotion communal emotion the
idea that you know like them people
they're fighting is bad you know uh so
that that works because of the
historical Factor too
uh but yeah he is so like not like I I
like it's like the prestige you know
like you're weird [ __ ] yeah it's like
the prestige is a weird movie yes but
it's awesome it's awesome it is you know
and I like that and it's got both it's
got all the high Concepts and all the
cool bells and whistles but it's also
got a an ingrained story about
characters an Interstellar is incredibly
emotional film
in spite of like whatever Weird Science
[ __ ] happens in it it's very emotional
like Matthew McConaughey is acting his
goddamn [ __ ] and it is heartbreak
it's melancholic my likes very it's kind
of a tragedy but it is and it's got that
whole love modeling like that that to me
is his most romanticized movie
especially from a character standpoint
and then his last couple films have been
like none of that who needs characters
yeah I don't wanna I don't want to feel
or Bond like I don't That's What actors
are for you come up with [ __ ] like what
I wonder cause like I feel like there is
the most if you don't like Interstellar
You could argue there's the most
emotional cheese in that movie and I
wonder if after that he it was like a
response of like all right I'm gonna go
away from from that kind of thing I'll
go away from being too emotional about
things he needs uh he needs that JJ love
your videos thank you who in your
opinion would make a good villain for
Avengers Secret Wars and who would you
cast I think it's King the Conqueror
and I would cast
Jonathan major
and I wouldn't cast Adam Driver I want
Modoc do it get Jim Carrey I wanted a
big surprise Modoc he's the ultimate get
the claymation uh Patton Oswald Modoc
uh yeah sorry it's important answers but
it sounds like it's gonna be those too I
can't really imagine that it being
anyone else Tia Carrera is Filipino she
should be in Avengers Secret Wars
toys for DCU Batman Nicholas Holt uh I
want Joe Coy I wanted Joe Coy Joe toy
Jacob battle on there you go he's big
he's got that vampire oh Jacob battle on
yeah yeah that's right [ __ ] yeah if I
get that guy yeah
exchanged Pride on that
Dolly de Leon there you go Leah Salonga
bigorist 84. how did you all handle your
mental health this year it was very up
and down I'll tell you the journey thank
you
um yeah I know it's very very deep down
well a lot of things to learn and it's
constant if
it's been a very very been very much had
myself laid out in front of me this year
it's been likewise good an eye-opening
and uh and hard but constructive
yeah I mean there's many miles to go I
haven't really evaluated what my mental
health was like this year but it was it
was life this year I would say a lot of
life sometimes it was amazing and great
and relaxing and fun and other times it
was really
stressful and hard and anxiety written
and panics driven it but I don't think I
had a panic attack this year I had like
two panic attacks last year yeah I think
I had panic attack this year
and one really bad panic attack last
year I wasn't like worried about getting
covered but I had a panic attack that
was so bad I was so weak and I had
chills and I got really sick that I
thought I had coveted and then I was
like oh I just had a panic attack my
body was just looking just chill stop
chill
in fact chills yeah yeah
but thank you for asking how was yours
Chelsea Brown hi
uh thank you you all did a great job on
that reaction oh I'm glad you liked it
I'm very excited to be doing Wednesday
with you how is it doing is it doing
well it is the worst reaction ever is it
getting views I hope so who's my concern
that's that's that's actually the
biggest association with mental health
is that my mice I'm always on my app I
was always checking the app the YouTube
app constantly just ciphering everything
what's been clean what I gotta fight
how's it doing all this one's not doing
well everything I need to change your
thumb no like this constant and I think
my mental health association with
YouTube is a little bit better but it
could be uh like this is like I really
love we haven't we've been doing live
streams twice in row and I I really I
was telling us to uh Paul recently and
Warren is that I really love doing live
streams I I they're fun to me they're
really fun and
um you know like we've been wanting to
do more things that involve us talking
and it's nice to be kind of
transitioning where we're a little bit
more common I think we're more like
we're still like the reaction category
but sometimes we were just commentating
and I like that a lot of those videos
have done much better this year of just
commentating instead of just watching us
watch something so I'm really happy
about that and and I think live streams
uh yeah you've done a really you've done
a really good job growing that stuff out
so of you I mean I'm here I I jump in
and say yes and and do my best to be
informed unless I should definitely not
because I'm reacting to this piece of
news
but uh sometimes I do
those are the most
weirdest answers with me or I'm like I'm
like wait John do you know about this
and it'll be like it's like I get this
feeling that John's like worried to say
he doesn't know about something like
you're not gonna get in trouble dude I'm
like you don't know about it and I'll be
and and I'll just wait to reserve over
on camera inside my mental dashboard I'm
like but there's so many worlds to know
there's so many details to stay abreast
of and on top of I'm so behind on so
many universes and it's like give me a
clear answer and then at the moment I'm
like oh [ __ ] I didn't read the news this
morning crap uh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna lead with no
and then discover that I have seen it
and come out with the opposite version
where it's less fun because then you're
like oh he does know
I come off as miserable my wife says oh
good
there's room for improvement yes yes
did we get that did we get that super
chat up there which one we got a mental
health but did we get that walk on there
oh no there you go Joshua fun fact about
oh sorry
take it away
oh and Wednesday is doing pretty well
right now oh is it I think so it seems
as though
oh Louise said talking about your mental
health saying you were only happy doing
live streams
it's a shame we should have streamed the
wedding is that what I said I said
honest honestly guys I'm Only Happy When
I'm live streaming I'm only a happy when
it's live I'm saying the the actual
doing of the content is the most fun and
and and sometimes it's the obsession
about around it that can be like it's
all the real world yeah I get a number I
can be upset yeah that that's the part
where I'm like I need to get off my
phone
it's like I like every hour I'm like
checking Twitter or something come out
something come out and sometimes that
Obsession can take a bit of it like and
if if there's like a few videos in a row
that aren't doing well I've gotten a
little bit better at going
it's all right but there is that part of
his like Channel's dead so it's dead
permanently like I think it happens at
least once a month probably it's dead
it's completely dead it's not gonna
bounce back I think that's that's the
yin yang we need to do for 2023 is is
you need to unplug a little more and I
need to plug in a bit more that'll be
our growth journey of 23. uh cameraman
fun fact
who's better Chris stuckman or Jeremy
Johns I love them both for what they do
man like they both give me something
different and
you know what's funny about stuckman
because of this new thing he does now or
he's talking to talk [ __ ] on movies
really yeah like he's done some reviews
where he will point out that criticisms
he has with it
I forgot well there was one movie he he
did something he did that on some movie
recently I forgot what [ __ ] movie it
was but
was it Thor love and thunder or what
Connor it was reconna forever he was
really honest about his criticisms with
that
um but generally if there's not a review
out for Chris stuckman movie yeah you
know you're like well we know it is a
picture of silence speaks volumes yeah
ain't stuck on that thing that's such a
fascinating thing he's kind of put
himself into because I'm like did you
see Black Adam man I don't see a review
out here
yeah yeah you gotta keep up with at
least that yeah I bet you saw this movie
dude no [ __ ]
I wonder what that I do wonder what that
convergence is for him of like I have to
talk about this whether I like it or not
or if he is truly at the point where
it's like ah if I really don't care
about her like it then I just don't have
to say a thing I think Jeremy John's if
you what's cool about Jeremy Johns is if
you look back at his older videos into
what he does now it's essentially the
same but better yeah and stronger more
refined and I think when you the the I I
love Stockman for the the transition
that he made from like it's fun to watch
his older videos where he is putting on
a bit of an act up yes and to see how
just like sincere he is now how relaxed
yeah whereas Jeremy John's
he's essentially doing this he reads
more genuine still but and I think that
that phrase brevity is the soul of wit I
think he really like is the master of
efficiency sure and and communicating
something right I don't feel like you
left something out of your talk I know
and I'll see the run times I'll be like
five minutes this review really and then
afterwards I'm like that's the full
comprehensive review yeah but what it
needed to be for his style and he's
still funny and and he looks like he
still really enjoys what he's doing and
he doesn't seem to conform I like I I
think they're both they both give me
something very different I love them
both they both seem to do a similar
spiritual thing in two completely kind
of opposite packages because yeah if you
want like the snappy and fun review you
go to Jeremy John's if you want the
thoughtful unpacking then you go to
Chris stuckman I think that's really
nice they're both doing genuine in a
different way I agree Amber with this
comment Amber Heard Happy New Year to
Australia
forever yeah the beach says
Sims are both filmed in my towns in
Puerto Rico Vega Baja and manati and
Logan Paul was right down the street oh
I love it I belong here I am
a Puerto Rican man respect me I actually
like this interview with Philip DeFranco
that's cool man dude let me get that
respect out there yeah yeah dude thank
you for the Super Chat Leonardo DiCaprio
should only date 18 year olds now and
really ride that line
I want more that's where the debate
would happen yes people being like creep
it's legal it's legal and he breaks up
with them when they turn 19. he's got a
whole year with each of them
doe eyes thank you Happy New Year Hits
10 million subscribers in 2023. oh dude
and a third season of loss of spookies
don't think I missed you no eyes I see
you out here I'm not gonna be sad I had
a great
I mean I think um
no it's okay honestly I was telling uh I
mean I'll get a tad personal I don't
like to talk about my relationship too
much I I've I I prefer to keep as much
of that part truly private but it does
feel more supportive and
more I do feel more people say you don't
really change them we haven't really
changed this game Mary but I do feel
like
better
I'll keep it in town without getting too
revealing about my my per I try to keep
my personal relationships personal and
then I will say like it does feel
assured like I was I've had whatever guy
fears that come up before a wedding but
weirdly the day of I was like not
panicking at all yeah I was like no I'm
making the right choice was happening
around yeah I was not panicked at all
about it this is the right choice I'm
good
I'm confident in what I'm doing right
now
it's a life-changing moment yeah and
just the way today hearing you in the
Stream being like I'm showing my wife
Breaking Bad I'm just like that sounds
right that sounds righter than it did
when you were like my fiance or whatever
you know it sounds the rightest version
you know words like girlfriend and
fiance are so long I know life is so
short wife wife it's just Direct
it's not complicated
um but no I had a good I had a good year
overall I think I had a really good year
my Charles had a really good year you
just blossomed my dude I would hate I
would hate to complain there are people
who really struggle and and I I'm really
great if there's I'm very grateful for
what this field it's something I never
thought would be it didn't start off as
a career Pursuit and it turned into a
career and it is uh giving me a new a
life
that I could have never
that I never knew I could truly achieve
that it always seemed like a distant
dream which is just be a bit of
financial stability and
be able to afford certain things you'd
be able to go instead of always being
like
you might see it all the time like this
hasn't really ever gone away from me the
viewer had Rich Dad Poor Dad I've
constantly had Poor Dad mentality even
when I've done well and edited and so
but to be here it's something I am very
grateful like something that sometimes I
have to do like check myself on and go
I'm always so used to just doing the now
work that sometimes I don't really
reflect on when I was just like working
a full-time job and then doing this and
and trying to get this to just replace
replace that job that's that's all I was
focused on and to be here now it's like
yeah it's kind of crazy you know like
because I'm I'm very grateful and um
so whenever I meet someone in person I'm
always like I gotta try to make
because I want to be
here
it's a great that's a great point of
gratitude yeah
yeah
yes that's true Greg lets his emotions
out
crying crying is the key what's you guys
choice of young Superman movie it's a
matter of the Henry situation but I
trust James Gunn John pick a guy uh
young Joe Coy and uh let's just you know
what pull uh
Filipino Superman Phillips make it
happen Joe Coy get uh uh you know the
the Freddie Freeman kid to do it once
they destroy Shazam put him in as young
Clark get him make it happen man make
him buff yeah
I don't know who's young and hot right
now and Charming uh how about Joe Kiri
young Superman I love it it wouldn't be
a bad choice it wouldn't be a bad choice
right all you got to do is get his voice
a little deeper but he can age into that
I just assumed Superman always has kind
of a soothing baritone
or or whatever's between that and Alto
Ryan Reynolds Ryan
the S stands for Hope faster than
speeding bullet
You're Gonna Leave tall buildings sing
about and vigorous 84. my mental health
was a bunch of up and downs but just
taking it one day at a time but we'll
love always love you all thank you that
is what mental health is that's what
life is is up and down ups and downs one
day at a time
sometimes you're going to be sad
sometimes I think I think it's the
it's the Journey of learning how to fix
set your feelings this is what life
mental health is really all about to be
here to learn how to accept yeah is the
it's the the journey I I constantly
think that's what it always comes back
to is
being okay with
like one time Brad Pitt I remember said
happiness was overrated and that turns
his whole conundrum but when I've read
the whole thing I was like I get what
he's getting at though is is you know
sometimes you you just I think that's
what he's essentially getting as like
sometimes you're just not gonna feel
happy and you gotta just deal with that
yeah and accept it yeah and if you were
happy all the time chances are they did
some [ __ ] on a plane so maybe it wasn't
the guy to talk to you about it
yeah I'm wondering I'm like when is the
what is what is the Brad Pitt situation
what do we feel about this guy uh yeah
yeah good question uh I've got to get
John out of here guys it's okay don't
worry about it hey real Regents
thank you real regions there's some good
movies but don't worry darling I've got
some people like it
thank you Alan hey guys I can't think of
anything to ask you guys just want to
say appreciate all your content it's
been helping me on my two hour commutes
to work and dealing with my depression
oh thank you Allen it's funny Eric
constant's very more like sometimes you
gotta watch it because it's especially
if it's reaction so people say that I'm
like how are you watching
that'd be uh dangerous but thank you man
love all the inserts especially guys
yeah that's good it's good I appreciate
it I do that I do that with a lot of
videos where I feel bad because then I'm
like I've had a lot of work went into
the visual side of this and I'm not
looking at any of that I'm so sorry for
the two-hour commutes that sounds like a
pain in the ass but yes if anything we
do to help you pass the time we'll do
our best Amber Autumn yes very Gemini of
me always it's I'm always of two minds
also John is garbage he's only happy
when it's live thank you hey Mom I'm
live streaming right now what's going on
what do you have to say to the reject
Nation Joyce mom
are you uh I think my mom butt dialed me
what are you most excited for in 2023
which movies do you want to see my mom
straight up my mother straight up butt
dialed Mom are you there
mom
mom
mama
it's my sister in the background
straight up
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
she said what's called Gregory Gregory
you're calling phone with me call him
you can call him anytime you want
I'm on a live stream mom we've been on
the phone for a minute yeah
I'm on a live stream what movies are you
looking forward to in 2023
okay bye
we're gonna be done hopefully in 10
minutes or so
bye
first reason why I love you in she
doesn't normally say it Quentin hung up
on her said tell me about the hell with
you I don't need you dude name one thing
you ever did for me my mom she's so
funny she cried at the wedding it was
sweet yeah it was uh that's very sweet
what's uh that is a question mark is
that is a huge question what is your
favorite franchise just generally ever
about all franchises Breaking Bad
wow it's coming here uh your core
reaction I think is coming tomorrow and
we really like that episode Lorenzo hey
hey look out for it
oh yeah that is done that is ready yeah
okay what time is it it's like three oh
my God John we got there
way longer than expect
Ed which Marvel movie are you it's that
g fuel are you satisfied with it would
take them in a different direction if
possible
um uh uh Thor seems to be everybody's
go-to yeah yeah I'd say that go go do
something new with Thor yeah
go do something fresh I think Mike
Flanagan making uh dark Towers would be
amazing that seems like the best chance
that property has it being good and
enjoyable
um damn we still got 385 people here
that's cool well you're 385 people
before you guys go if you could leave a
like that would be amazing it would be
um thank you for helping us have an
amazing year thank you guys again so
much for being incredible
and um
we're gonna be having I mean I'm going
to be getting a video up on uh
Monday I think or Tuesday I'm not sure
but uh we're gonna be taking the first
couple days off because it's my fault I
had the days I sketch I was just trying
to map out as all our students and most
of our to do most of them I'd say uh
throughout the week and and I was a day
I thought today was going to be the 30th
not the 31st and and so uh yeah we're
gonna take Sunday and Monday off I'm
gonna try to do that at least but yeah
we'll be checking back in early on in
the year thank you guys so much for
being here and don't we have to air we
do the shout out we're gonna end this
with Airy because we gotta we got
patrons who Pledge Your tear where they
deserve some shout outs we're gonna play
that video
um John remove the chat for now please
of course
thank you guys uh and thank you for
spending your New Year's Eve or New
Year's Day with us for the moment in
time and I hope you guys have a
wonderful 2023 and please stick around
with us for next year and uh leave a
like that's also so important leave that
damn huge thank you John for uh sending
this whole stream up absolute vodka
being here with me on New Year's Eve
wouldn't want to be here with anyone
else especially my wife dude I'm glad
she is nowhere near us right now so we
can have man time that now we will never
have because you are married air that
awkward shout outs best man
here we go love you all peace
man I want to shout out my man Roberto
ankle man
you're fine
are you a snack cause cause Taki
kirataki like like the snack you're
attractive
and Simon
no more denying
song High Glover puts a song in my heart
Jacob Neptune I'll see you on the sand
dunes
Mitchell I'd walk with you through the
field of reeds
an enemy you think you're the real G
I want to jump in a hot spring without a
ling
Logan Burton and your name I mean
cursing
I am here for you
every cons 39.
you gotta sign
that over your body I'm going down
the cutie Cutie
Nick X
terminate
don't settle for the basic when you can
get Jeffrey W premium
get out of here man I want a snail mail
with Dale Ferguson
just rhymes for Gail
when are the Ultimate Party Planner
[Music]
I feel awful
passing out some flyers with Aaron Myers
bastard
differently saying no not the same as
anybody others says sanity it's you
go
Lauren American Horse taking the World
by force
simply faded
into the Dust
Joe and a Saint Louis
[Music]
I'm about to set yourself free
Safari Jackalope 94. Justin Martin
Rosie baby clean that lady love you dear
calling I know you as my Joseph Stalin
Philip Justice Smith Jr
Janet Smith
Marines
Melanie LeBlanc I returned to you now
Melanie
I was the lord of the ring for you
that's so much a pleasure to our patreon
page and for having us have a happiness
successful year with having it we did it
guys we shouted you out shout out now
2023 is going to look
decay
talking give up now all kinds of global
all hope speeding up
yeah man the Sun is hot what are you
gonna do you better look out you better
not cry
sometimes tell you why
Greg and John are coming to your house
to check on you yeah make sure you're
all right you never know you never know
sometimes people get sick out there
don't start your cars kill people yeah
thanks for being here
I think this is improv I think yes I
agree and furthermore it's time to end
this live stream
[Music]